Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. When great waves break, there is a moment when it seems as if everything in their way must be destroyed. Even those who have watched the water rising, and guessed the force of the wind and the tides driving it, are shocked by the vehemence of the impact. But in that same moment, the destructive force of the wave is temporarily spent. Whatever has been unable to withstand it is safe in the slack waters of the trough until the next wave breaks.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当巨大的海浪汹涌拍岸时，总会有那么一瞬间，仿佛挡在它面前的一切都将被摧毁。甚至连那些目睹海潮上涨、预料到驱动它的风浪威力的人，也为这冲击的猛烈感到震惊。但在同一时刻，海浪的破坏力却在暂时消退。无论有什么东西没能经受住它的考验，都会在低谷的缓流中安然无恙，直到下一次海浪拍击。
For nearly five years, since the assassination of President Kennedy, two long waves of danger had been racing toward the safe and settled shore where most Americans live. The danger of war from Southeast Asia and the danger of rebellion in the heart of American cities. The first week of April 1968 was the week the waves broke. So those were the opening lines of the suitably named An American Melodrama, a book about the presidential election of 1968 by three journalists working for the Sunday Times here in London, hence the very portentous British accent with which I did that reading, Dominic. You have put down in
近五年来，自肯尼迪总统遇刺以来，两股漫长的危险巨浪一直朝着大多数美国人居住的那个安全且安定的海岸汹涌奔腾。来自东南亚的战争危险，以及美国城市核心地带的叛乱危险。1968年4月的第一周，就是巨浪拍岸的那一周。因此，上面那段话是《一场美式闹剧》（An American Melodrama）这本书的开场白。这本书由伦敦《星期日泰晤士报》的三位记者撰写，讲述的是1968年总统大选的故事——正因如此，我刚才朗读时才带上了那种极其自命不凡的英国腔，多米尼克。你在笔记中写下了
your notes, 1968, the most tumultuous year in modern American history. And you would know because this is absolutely your subject, isn't it? This is the background to your doctorate. You know everything about this. And on that level, it's very exciting. We're doing 1968 in the US. But also, of course, we're doing this against the backdrop of the presidential election in 2024, which will be ongoing as these episodes go out. So perfect timing in every way. And there are loads of parallels, which we'll be exploring in this series. Hello, everybody. Yes, this is a tremendously exciting subject.
1968年，现代美国历史上最动荡的一年。你当然很清楚，因为这绝对是你的专业领域，不是吗？这是你攻读博士学位的背景。你对这一切了如指掌。从这个层面来看，这非常令人兴奋。我们正在探讨美国的1968年。当然，我们这也是在2024年美国总统大选的背景下展开的，这些节目播出时大选正在进行。所以从各方面来看，时机都堪称完美。其中有大量的相似之处，我们将在本系列中进行探讨。大家好。是的，这是一个极其令人兴奋的主题。
So as you say, Tom, this is the subject I wrote my doctorate about. That book that you quoted, An American Melodrama is a brilliant book, actually. One of the best books ever written, I think, about American politics. It was by three Sunday Times journalists. And one of them, Godfrey Hodgson, was actually a great inspiration to me when I was doing my studies on this. He had a brilliant contact book, knew loads of people from the Kennedy campaign, the Johnson White House and so on. He was able to open his contact book and I got to interview all these people. It was brilliant and it's such a rich subject because this was a year for people who don't know why we've
正如你所说，汤姆，这就是我写博士论文的主题。你刚才引用的那本书——《一场美式闹剧》其实是一本极其精彩的书。我认为它是关于美国政治的最佳著作之一。作者是《星期日泰晤士报》的三位记者。其中一位叫戈弗雷·霍奇森（Godfrey Hodgson），我在对此进行研究时，他实际上给了我很大的启示。他有着极其丰富的人脉网，认识肯尼迪竞选团队、约翰逊白宫等各方的大量人物。他当时向我敞开了他的人脉录，我得以采访了所有人。这太棒了，而且这是一个极其丰富的主题，因为对于那些不知道我们为什么
chosen this particular year to do a series about. It was the year that was the bloodiest year of the Vietnam War. It saw the fall of President Lyndon Johnson who seemed all-conquering, you know, unassailable. It was the year that Martin Luther King was assassinated, a moment that was followed by riots in American cities. It saw the sort of doomed romantic campaign of Robert Kennedy and his assassination in Los Angeles, California, where Tom, we will be arriving ourselves in a doomed campaign of our own to do a Rest is History live show. Although hopefully we won't get shot in the kitchens.
选择这个特定年份来做一个系列节目的听众来说，这是越南战争中最血腥的一年。这一年，看起来似乎无所不能、坚不可摧的林登·约翰逊总统黯然下台。这一年，马丁·路德·金遇刺身亡，随之而来的是美国各大城市的骚乱。这一年，罗伯特·肯尼迪进行了他那场注定失败的浪漫主义竞选，并在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶遇刺身亡——汤姆，我们自己也将踏上一场注定失败的旅程，去那里举办一场《历史的余烬》现场秀。不过希望我们不会在厨房里挨枪子。
Yeah, I'm not going to go into the kitchens of any hotels just in case. It's a real sort of landmark year in American political history because it sees the emergence of a new kind of right-wing populism in the form of Governor George C. Wallace, who mounts an independent campaign for the presidency, which is better than any independent campaign for, what, 50 years or more, and is incredibly influential. There is then this extraordinary set piece of the riots at the Chicago Democratic Convention, a clash between the Chicago police and anti-war demonstrators, the so-called Yippies. I love a Yippie.
是的，为了以防万一，我不会去任何酒店的厨房。这堪称美国政治史上的一个真正的里程碑之年，因为随着乔治·C·华莱士（George C. Wallace）州长的出现，一种新型的右翼民粹主义登上政治舞台。他以独立候选人身份竞选总统，其战绩比过去50年或更长时间里的任何独立竞选都要好，并且产生了极其深远的影响。接着是芝加哥民主党全国代表大会上那场非同寻常的重头戏——骚乱，芝加哥警方与反战示威者（即所谓的“嬉皮士”）爆发了冲突。我可太喜欢嬉皮士了。
Played out on national television before an audience of tens of millions. And then finally, as if all this is not dramatic enough, the year ends with one of the great comebacks in American history. The comeback of Richard Nixon, who'd been written off a few years earlier, but wins the presidency in quite controversial circumstances to become one of the most consequential and indeed controversial presidents of modern times. So it's an extraordinary, I think it's the succession of events piled up on top of one another. Do you think also, I mean, speaking as a non-specialist, it's also the fact that the soundtrack is brilliant.
这场冲突通过全国电视直播展现在数千万观众面前。然后，仿佛这一切还不够戏剧化，这一年以美国历史上最大的一次政治东山再起画上了句号。理查德·尼克松的复出，他几年前曾被看衰，却在颇具争议的情况下赢得总统大选，成为了现代最具影响力、也确实最具争议的总统之一。因此，这是一个非同寻常的年份，我想说的是一连串事件接踵而至。作为一个非专业人士，你是否也觉得，这里的配乐实在太精彩了？
Of course. So you have this amazing music, it's got hippies, all that kind of stuff. Absolutely. And you know what it makes me think of Dominic? The list of all the things that you were describing. It makes me think of one of the big singles of that year, which is Jimi Hendrix's all along the watch tower. There's too much confusion.
当然。所以你有这种绝妙的音乐，里面有嬉皮士，还有所有诸如此类的东西。绝对是这样。你知道这让我想起了什么吗，多米尼克？你刚才描述的所有那些事情的清单。它让我想起了那一年的一首热门单曲，也就是吉米·亨德里克斯（Jimi Hendrix）的《顺风瞭望塔》（All Along the Watchtower）。混乱太多了。
I can't get no relief. Yeah. It does feel like that. I mean, some of these events that we're describing, so the fall of Johnson, the assassination of King, the assassination of Kennedy, these happen within days or weeks of one another. At the end of the year, Time magazine said it had been, and I quote, one damn thing after another, indeed, one tragic, surprising and perplexing
我简直无法解脱。没错，确实有这种感觉。我的意思是，我们正在描述的一些事件，比如约翰逊的下台、金的遇刺、肯尼迪的遇刺，这些都在彼此相隔几天或几周内相继发生。到了年底，《时代》周刊称其为——我引述一下——“接二连三的糟糕事”，确切地说，是一桩桩悲剧性、令人惊愕且困惑的事情接踵而至，
thing after another, and it said that events had been moving at the pace of an avant-garde movie edited by Mad Clutter. And this is an age when there's a lot of avant-garde movies with mad clutter. Yeah. It's exactly as you say, it's the sense of a succession of events, each one of which would be enough for one year, but played out against a soundtrack of the doors and Jimi Hendrix. All of that extraordinary music, kind of outlandish fashion, protests and universities, college
该杂志还称，事件的发展速度就像是一部由疯狂剪辑师剪辑的前卫电影。这是一个充斥着大量剪辑疯狂的前卫电影的时代。是的。正如你所说，这就是那种事件连环爆发的感觉，其中任何一桩都足以充当整年的大事件，却伴随着门乐队（The Doors）和吉米·亨德里克斯的音乐背景轰轰烈烈地上演。所有那些非同寻常的音乐、奇特的时尚、大学校园里的抗议活动，诸如此类。人们嘴里总是挂满“老兄”（man）。是的，还有糟糕透顶的俚语。
campuses, all of that kind of thing. People saying man a lot. Yes, and terrible, terrible slang. Yeah. I think brilliant slang actually. So in today's episode, we'll be talking about the agony of the Vietnam War and the fall of Lyndon Johnson. So perhaps we should set the scene by picking up from the last time we went to 60s America,
是的。不过我觉得其实是很精彩的俚语。所以在今天的节目中，我们将讨论越战的痛苦以及林登·约翰逊的下台。所以也许我们应该回顾一下上次我们涉足60年代美国时的情景来铺垫一下背景，
which was our series that we did about the assassination of President Kennedy in 1963, which of course, those Sunday Times journalists mentioned. So listeners to that series will remember that one of the final scenes was that moment aboard Air Force One, where Lyndon Johnson, standing next to a blood stained Jackie Kennedy, swears the oath of office and becomes Kennedy's successor. And Johnson is a brilliant character. He's like a character from Suetonius's The Twelve Caesars. Well, nothing wrong with that. So to give people a sense of who Johnson is, Johnson turned 60 in 1968. He came from the Texas Hill country. His father was a kind of failed farmer who'd had to sell the family ranch and the poverty, the humiliation entered into his soul.
也就是我们制作的关于1963年肯尼迪总统遇刺案的系列节目，当然，《星期日泰晤士报》的那几位记者也提到了这一点。听过那个系列的听众会记得，其中最后的场景之一，就是在空军一号上那一刻：林登·约翰逊站在沾满鲜血的杰奎琳·肯尼迪身旁，宣誓就职并成为肯尼迪的继任者。约翰逊是一个极其精彩的人物。他就像是苏维埃托尼乌斯笔下《十二帝王传》里的角色。嗯，这倒也没什么不对的。为了让大家对约翰逊有个概念，约翰逊在1968年满60岁。他来自德克萨斯州的山区。他的父亲是一个某种意义上破产的农场主，不得不卖掉家族牧场，贫困与屈辱深深烙印在他的灵魂里。
So he is somebody who rather like Richard Nixon. I was going to say, I mean, it's quite a Nixon quality to that. Definitely. He is driven by this insecurity and this feeling of humiliation all his life. He became a teacher and he genuinely had a social conscience. He's very moved by the poverty and the deprivation of the Mexican children that he teaches down there in Texas. So that's important to emphasize because the image that you get of him is a man who is
因此，他是一个相当类似于理查德·尼克松的人。我正想说，这其实很有尼克松的特质。确实如此。他一生都被这种不安全感和屈辱感驱使着。他当过教师，并且确实拥有社会良知。他被他在德克萨斯州教书的那些墨西哥儿童的贫困与剥夺深深触动。所以这一点非常重要，必须强调，因为你对他留下的印象是一个
motivated by a kind of ruthless lust for power. Which is true. But not just by that. No, exactly. The classic thing that American historians say about Lyndon Johnson, I mean, the one word they always use is tragic. They say he is a man of tremendous gifts, of extraordinary political talent, probably unmatched among post-war presidents. Because he's a fixer, isn't he, before he becomes a vice president and then president. He's a brilliant, brilliant fixer. but he is also a monster as we will go on to discuss.
被某种对权力的残酷渴望所驱使的人。这确实是真的。但不仅限于此。不，完全如此。美国历史学家对林登·约翰逊有一个经典的评价，他们经常用的一个词就是“悲剧”。他们说他是一个天赋异禀、拥有非凡政治才能的人，在战后历任总统中可以说是无出其右。因为他在成为副总统进而成为总统之前，是个幕后运作的高手，不是吗？他是一个绝顶聪明的政治掮客。但与此同时，正如我们接下来要讨论的，他也是个怪物。
He is in many ways a horrendous man, but one who also has this side that is genuinely progressive and public spirited and has a genuine kind of altruism to it. And you mentioned Suetonius, the great Roman biographer, but Lyndon Johnson is the subject of what people are always saying is the greatest modern political biography. Yeah. And I have to say I've never read it because it's about 4,000 pages long, isn't it? Yeah. And he's only got up to about kind of 1932 or something. No, I think Johnson has become, I can't actually remember where he's got to, has he maybe become vice president? Robert Caro's enormous, enormous cycle of Johnson biographies, which I have
他在许多方面是个可怕的人，但同时也有真正开明、具有公共精神和纯粹利他主义的一面。你提到了伟大的罗马传记作家苏维埃托尼乌斯，而林登·约翰逊正是人们常说的最伟大的现代政治传记的主人公。是的。我必须承认我从来没读过它，因为它大约有4000页长，对吧？是的，而且他当时只写到了1932年左右。不，我觉得约翰逊已经——我其实记不清他写到哪儿了，他可能当上副总统了吗？罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）那部皇皇巨著般的约翰逊传记系列，我必须承认我都读过，尽管它们有时让人着迷到催眠的程度，但有时你催眠到甚至有点昏昏欲睡，因为里面的细枝末节实在太繁琐了。不过，他对约翰逊职业生涯的宏大广度，以及驱动着他的这双重力量，给出了极其精彩的诠释。一方面是行善的愿望，另一方面则是那种怪异的、对权力和控制的强迫性渴望。他曾是德克萨斯州的国会议员。他在1948年通过赤裸裸的、明目张胆的舞弊进入了参议院。
read I have to say, although they're both hypnotic at times, but there are moments when you're so hypnotized you're slightly falling asleep because the minutiae are so involved. But he gives a brilliant sense of the kind of sweep of Johnson's career and of these twin forces that are driving him on. On the one hand, the desire to do good, on the other, the kind of monstrousness, the obsessive, the lust for power and for control. He was a congressman in Texas. He got into the Senate in 1948 through unashamed, flagrant fraud.
约翰逊是个行事肮脏的家伙。但自从1948年进入参议院后，他成为了多数党领袖。因此他领导着民主党人。正如你所说，他不只是个幕后运作的掮客。他是美国历史上最天才的政治操盘手。他发明了一种叫做“约翰逊式压迫”（the Johnson treatment）的手腕。我实在想象不出你会喜欢这个，汤姆。约翰逊是个身材魁梧的大块头，他会居高临下地逼近你，对你喋喋不休，
He's a dirty guy, Johnson. But once he was in the Senate after 1948, he became majority leader. So he leads the Democrats. And as you said, he's not just a fixer. He is the most brilliant political manager in American history. He does something called the Johnson treatment. I can't really see you enjoying this, Tom. Johnson is a huge man and he would loom over you and he would talk to you and at you.
如果有必要甚至能持续数小时，他的手会一直在你身上动个不停。人们经常引用《华盛顿邮报》主编本·布拉德利（Ben Bradley）的话来形容那种感觉：就像一只圣伯纳犬舔了你的脸一个小时，然后把你整个人揉捏了一通。所以他会试图说服你，我不知道，比如不要去查塔姆步行街（Chatham High Street）拍节目什么的。完全正确，他会这么干。而且他消息灵通。他知道你的弱点，也知道你的长处。他的手会自始至终搭在你身上。他会说：“汤姆，我知道你想要这个。我知道你想要那个。你有你的保加利亚私人教练。”是的。“我知道你和你家人是怎么回事。”然后他会把钱塞进你的口袋。
If necessary for hours, his hands would be all over you. People would often say what Ben Bradley, who edited the Washington Post, said it was as if a St. Bernard had licked your face for an hour and had poured you all over. So he'd be trying to say, I don't know, don't do an episode on Chatham High Street or something like that. Exactly, he would. And he would know he would have intelligence. He would know your weaknesses. He would know your strengths. His hands would literally be on you the whole time. And he would be saying, Tom, I know you want this. I know you this. You've got your Bulgarian personal trainer. Yeah. I know what's going on with you and your family. And he'd be stuffing money in your pockets.
然后他还会不会提议说我们一起去洗手间，接着以一种具有恐吓意味的方式小便？这是真的吗？这绝对是真的。所以这是约翰逊的另一面，听众可能会觉得很有趣。他非常迷恋排泄物相关的粗俗笑话。所以有一段非常著名的对话你其实可以听到。他在白宫里录下了自己的谈话。哦，又跟尼克松一样。
And then also, mightn't he suggest that we go to the urinal together and he would then urinate in an intimidating manner? Is that true? It's absolutely true. So this is another side to Johnson, which listeners may find entertaining. He's very scatological. So there's a very famous conversation that you can hear. He taped his conversations in the White House. Oh, like Nixon again.
你可以在网上听到。他打电话给一家服装公司订购一些裤子。那是1964年，他当时是总统。他针对裤裆的设计发了一通长篇大论。而且他非常、非常直白地谈论他身体的“装备”，以及他想让它在身体的什么位置下垂。这很有约翰逊的风格。他会在马桶上开会。他会把助手们叫来——通常是那些常春藤盟校毕业、自诩有着肯尼迪式精致做派、依然留在白宫的助手们，约翰逊会说：“请进来跟我谈话。”
You can hear it online. He rings a clothing company to order some trousers. This is 1964 and he's president. And there's a huge sort of rant he goes on about the crotch of the trousers. And he's very, very explicit about his equipment and where he wants it to hang, to hang around his body. And this is typical of Johnson. He will have meetings on the toilet. He will call aides, often Ivy League educated, sort of self-consciously sophisticated kind of Kennedy aides who are still in the White House, Johnson will say, come in please to talk to me.
而他当时就大喇喇地坐在马桶上。就像加图（Cato）接见来自埃及的使节一样。没错，完全就是这样。他们会觉得这是一种贬低和羞辱，但他是总统，他们对此无可奈何。他简直就是个“大雕”巨鳄。好吧，他会在女秘书面前在洗手池里小便，会把英国小报曾经称之为他“男子气概”的东西在人前挥舞。他的“约翰逊”。他的约翰逊就在众人面前晃荡。他背叛他的妻子伯德夫人（Lady Bird），在妻子面前对
And he will literally be sitting on the toilet. So like Cato receiving ambassadors from Egypt. Exactly, exactly. And they will find it degrading, humiliating, but he's the president and there's nothing they can do about it. He's literally the big swinging dick. Well, he will urinate in the washbasin in front of his secretaries. He will wave his, what the tabloids in Britain would once have called his manhood around. His Johnson. His Johnson in front of people. He cheats on his wife, Lady Bird. He gropes
女性动手动脚。他曾说过一句我必须承认相当经典的话：“我偶然得到的女人，比肯尼迪处心积虑弄到的还要多。”所以多米尼克，我能问你个问题吗？当然。因为我相信作为这个话题的世界级专家，这一定会让你兴奋不已。世界级专家，哇。那就是我竟然读了一本书。这太令人兴奋了。
women in front of her. He has this line, which I have to say is quite a good line. I've had more women by accident than Kennedy had on purpose. So Dominic, can I just ask you something? Yeah. Because I'm sure it will thrill you as a world expert on this topic. World experts, wow. To know that I have read a book. That's exciting.
为了做这期节目所做的准备。这既令人兴奋，又让人感到恐惧。没错。所以我现在武装了一些微不足道的知识碎片，可以用它们来惊艳你或者激怒你。是的。这本书的作者叫卢克·A·尼克特（Luke A. Nickter），从他的照片来看，他长着一张喜欢系领结的脸。
In preparation for this. That's exciting, but also terrifying. Yeah. Exactly. So I'm now armed with little scraps of knowledge with which I can impress and infuriate you. Yes. So this is by a guy called Luke A. Nickter, who's from his photograph. He has the look of a man who would enjoy wearing a bow tie. And
书名叫《破碎的政治之年》（The Year That Broke Politics）。内容全关于1968年。他引用了福音派基督教领袖比利·格雷厄姆（Billy Graham）的话，据说后者是约翰逊的挚友。比利·格雷厄姆谈到约翰逊和伯德夫人时说：“我深表怀疑，世上是否还有哪对夫妇能比这俩人更深爱彼此。”这准确吗？还是说比利·格雷厄姆只是——我的意思是，他是疯了吗？我不觉得比利·格雷厄姆疯了。我觉得比利·格雷厄姆说得非常温和。好吧。我觉得伯德夫人对约翰逊忠心耿耿，而约翰逊以一种奇特的方式对她也是如此。从某种意义上说，他们对彼此非常忠诚，但约翰逊是个——美国人怎么说来着？他是个“色鬼”。
it's called The Year That Broke Politics. It's all about 1968. And he quotes Billy Graham, the evangelical Christian leader, who's apparently a big friend of Johnson. And he says about Johnson at LBJ and Lady Bird, I seriously doubt if any couple could love each other more than these two. Is that accurate or is Billy Graham just, I mean, is he, is he mad? I don't think Billy Graham is mad. I think Billy Graham has been very kind. Right. I think Lady Bird is devoted to Johnson and he in a peculiar way is to her. They're very loyal to each other in one sense, but Johnson is a, Johnson is one of, what's the people say in America? He's a dog.
“一放出家门就收不回来的恶犬。”大概是这个说法。好吧。是的，所以比利·格雷厄姆并不是完全说对了。没错。约翰逊是一个有着极度膨胀自我的人。我的意思是，汤姆，既然我们现在已经成了成功人士，或者说是相当成功的播客主，我们也该这么干。
He's a dog that you can't keep on the porch. I think is the expression. Okay. Yeah. So Billy Graham's not entirely right there. Right. Johnson is a man of towering ego. I mean, we should do this, Tom, now that we are successful or reasonably successful podcasters.
他的皮带扣上、短裤上、袖扣上都刻有他的缩写——LBJ。当你去德克萨斯州的LBJ牧场时，你会发现每样东西上都印着LBJ。甚至连烟灰缸上都印着，就好像他随时会忘记自己的名字一样。他极其专横，盛气凌人。当然，这一切背后的驱动力，正是这种对关注和关爱的渴望，一种近乎疯狂的执念。
He has his initials, LBJ, on his belt buckle, on his shorts, on his cufflinks. When you go to the LBJ ranch in Texas, LBJ is stamped on everything. It's even stamped on the ashtrays, like as if there's a danger that he'll forget his own name. He's very overbearing. He's very domineering. And of course, what this is driven by is this thirst, this almost demented obsession with getting attention and affection.
他总是对他的亲信说：“每个人都在反对我。所有人都鄙视我。”引述他的原话：“每个人都想把我拉下马。每个人都想击垮我。每个人都想毁灭我。”请问，这是他担任肯尼迪副总统时的经历留下的阴影吗？因为众所周知，是谁说过当副总统不值一钱或类似的话来着？对，所有人。所有人都这么说。
He's always sort of saying to his intimates, everybody's against me. Everybody despises me. And I quote, everybody is trying to cut me down. Everybody is trying to cut me down. Everybody is trying to destroy me. Can I ask, is this a residue of his experience as Kennedy's vice president? Because notoriously, who is it says that being vice president isn't worth a bucket of warm spit or something to that effect? Yeah, everybody. Everybody says that.
是的，所以这是一种体制化的羞辱过程。是的。我觉得这其中有一定程度的真相。所以我想他在肯尼迪白宫里基本上处于最底层。正如我们在过几期后制作罗伯特·肯尼迪专题节目时所要探讨的，罗伯特·肯尼迪和约翰逊之间的宿怨，部分原因就在于约翰逊觉得自己备受鄙视。因为这里面有着非常
Yes. So it's a kind of institutionalized process of humiliation. Yes. I think there's a degree of truth in that. So I think he had been very much at the bottom of the table in the Kennedy White House. And as we'll discuss when we do our episode about Robert Kennedy in a couple of episodes time, the feud between Robert Kennedy and Johnson was partly predicated on the fact that Johnson felt despised. Because there's a very
明显的阶级因素。因为肯尼迪家族全都是贵族预科学校和欧洲度假之类的背景。没错。他们的烟灰缸上可不会印着自己的缩写。坦白说，他们把约翰逊视为我们所说的“粗鄙之辈”，认为他粗俗、低级、举止粗鲁。罗伯特·肯尼迪绝对是这么想的。现在，在约翰·F·肯尼迪遇刺身亡后，约翰逊非常清楚，许多肯尼迪的亲信都鄙视他。他们认为他是个篡位者。他根本不该坐在那个位置上。他在媒体界的一个朋友、专栏作家盖伊·威廉·怀特（Guy William White）在1966年写道：“约翰逊总统不得不承受一种可怕的负担，那就是肯尼迪崇拜者们那永无休止的敌意。”
class element there. Because the Kennedys are all prep schools and holidays in Europe and stuff. Exactly. They don't have their initials stamped on their ashtrays. And they regard Johnson frankly, I think as common as what we call common, as vulgar, as coarse, as boorish. Certainly Robert Kennedy does. Now after John F. Kennedy is shot, it is very clear to Johnson that a lot of the Kennedy people despise him. They think he's a usurper. He shouldn't be there. One of his sort of friends in the media, Guy William White, a columnist, wrote in 1966, President Johnson has had to bear a frightful burden in the unremitting hostility of the Kennedy cult.
“而普遍的态度是，白宫里这个人不仅是一个宪法意义上的继任者，而是一个粗俗的篡位者。”但此时还没有出现他是肯尼迪刺杀案幕后黑手的谣言吧？还没有那种经历，对吧？没有，没有。那是70年代左右才发展出来的阴谋论。但我认为，对于许多肯尼迪阵营的律师来说，这就好比在伤口上撒盐——这个被他们视为有点怪物的德克萨斯乡巴佬，居然继承了他们英雄的衣钵。
And it's common attitude that the man in the White House is not simply a constitutional successor but a crude usurper. But there isn't at this point the rumours that he might be behind the Kennedy assassination. It's not that experience yet. No, no, no. That's the 70s kind of development. But I think for a lot of the Kennedy lawyers, it feels like it's poured salt in the wounds that this guy from Texas, who they regard as sort of slightly monstrous, has inherited
而对此感受最深的人就是罗伯特·肯尼迪。他曾是他兄弟的司法部长，觉得自己继承了他兄弟的火焰，可以说他是肯尼迪忠实拥趸心中的伟大传奇英雄。现在，约翰逊对罗伯特·肯尼迪鄙视至极。他总是叫他“那个男孩”，并且留存了一份关于他的档案，因为他担心总有一天罗伯特·肯尼迪会从背后捅他刀子。这再次说明，这非常具有罗马帝国的色彩。
their hero's mantle. And the person who really feels this is Robert Kennedy, who'd been attorney general to his brother, who feels that he has inherited his brother's flame, as it were, and who is this great sentimental hero of the Kennedy loyalists. Now Johnson despises Robert Kennedy. He always calls him that boy and he keeps a file on him because he fears that one day Robert Kennedy will stab him in the back. Again, it's very Roman actually.
是的，确实如此。然而，起初这一切似乎并不符合逻辑，因为LBJ在1964年大选中赢得了巨大的胜利。1964年的大选恰好发生在JFK遇刺仅仅一年后。约翰逊赢得了美国总统大选中历史上最高得票率。他以61%对39%击败了巴里·戈德水原（Barry Goldwater）。尽管意味深长的是，他输掉了深南部的五个州，而这正是本系列后面将要探讨的事态发展的预兆。
Yeah, it is. Yeah. However, at first it doesn't seem like that's at all plausible because LBJ wins a tremendous victory in 1964, in the 1964 election, which is just a year after JFK was shot. Johnson won the highest ever share of the vote in an American presidential election. He beat Barry Goldwater 61% to 39%. Although tellingly he lost the five states of the deep south and that is an omen of things to come that we'll be picking up on later in this series.
因为LBJ继承了肯尼迪对民权的承诺。他继承了这一承诺，并且将其进一步深化。因此，肯尼迪是否能让那些民权立法在国会通过，其实是个未知数。而约翰逊凭借他人脉网络、凭借“约翰逊式压迫”、凭借他无与伦比的交际手腕，成功推动通过了两项《民权法案》和一个《选举权法案》。他推行了他所谓的“伟大社会”（Great Society）计划，这是一项针对医疗和教育的大规模新支出计划，比如医疗保险（Medicare）和医疗补助（Medicaid）——我们的许多美国听众，或者说所有美国听众都会对此
Because LBJ has inherited Kennedy's commitment to civil rights. He's inherited it, but he also deepens it. So whether Kennedy could have got that civil rights legislation through his dubious. Johnson because of his contacts, because of the Johnson treatment, because of all his unparalleled networking skills, he is able to push through two civil rights acts and a voting rights act. He pushes through what he calls the great society, which is a huge program of new spending on health and education, programs like Medicare and Medicaid that a lot of our American listeners, well, all of our American listeners will be
感到熟悉，还有他所发动的所谓“向贫困宣战”（war on poverty）。因此，通过经济增长以及不断扩大的财政赤字，投入了数十亿美元，开展了一项史无前例的立法计划——我想我们在欧洲可能会称之为社会民主主义式的立法——旨在改善美国最贫困人口的生活。这就是为什么历史学家经常说约翰逊是一个悲剧人物，因为他们看到这些时——许多倾向于中左翼自由派的历史学家——会说：“哦，这太棒了，简直看不够。太爱了。”然而到了1967年左右，随着我们逼近1968年，人们开始感觉到
familiar with and what he calls a war on poverty. So spending billions of dollars, largely through economic growth, but also through widening deficits in an unprecedented program of what we, I guess, would call in Europe, social democratic kind of legislation to improve the lives of some of the poorest people in America. So this is why historians often say Johnson is a tragic figure, because they look at this, a lot of historians who tend to be kind of left of center liberal, they say, oh, this is brilliant, can't get enough of this. Love it. And yet by about 1967, so as we approach 1968, there was a sense that
事情开始出岔子了。有两个显而易见的原因。也就是你一开始宣读的那篇《星期日泰晤士报》文章中所提到的两点。第一点就是大规模的城市骚乱。也就是内城区的骚乱，基本上就是这样。所以这最初是从瓦茨（Watts）开始的吗？
things have started to go wrong. And there are two obvious things. I mean, these are the two things that are mentioned by that Sunday Times piece that you read out at the beginning. Number one is massive urban unrest. So riots in the inner cities, effectively. So that started in Watts. And are these race-based riots?
嗯，是的，这些骚乱主要是由非裔美国人发起的，通常是由警察暴力执法以及对当局的不满所引发的。人们普遍有一种感觉，即民权运动和抗议活动已经向北方蔓延。变得更加激进了，比如黑豹党。是的，它变得更加激进，但这并不是这些骚乱爆发的真正原因。骚乱爆发是因为在住房、就业以及虐待问题上的紧张局势不断加剧，也是因为北方城市或西海岸城市的种族主义问题。
Well, yeah, they are largely riots by African Americans and they are often inspired by police brutality, by resentment of the authorities. There's a sort of sense that the civil rights movement and the campaign has moved northwards. Become a bit more militant, Black Panthers. Yeah, it's becoming more militant, but that's not really why these riots are breaking out. The riots are breaking out because there's growing tension over housing, over jobs, and over mistreatment, but over racism in the Northern cities or the cities of the West Coast.
但在大学里，那是爱之夏（summer of love），不是吗？嗯，其实不太算是爱之夏。那更像是一个抗议之夏。因此，1967年的爱之夏显然是在旧金山市的公园里上演的，但在校园里，正如我们所见，与其说是和平与爱，不如说是日益痛苦、充满激情的反战示威。不过我们稍后会谈到这一点。就骚乱而言，它们于1964年在洛杉矶的瓦茨区爆发。接着是1966年漫长而炎热的夏天，然后是1967年更漫长、更炎热的夏天。
But in universities, it's the summer of love, isn't it? Well, not quite a summer of love, actually. It's more a summer of protest. So the summer of love in 1967 is obviously in the sort of parks of San Francisco, but on campuses, as we will see, it's not so much peace and love. It's increasingly embittered, impassioned anti-war demonstrations. But we'll get onto that. Just on the riots, they cook off in Watson, Los Angeles in 1964. Then there's a long hot summer in 1966 and then a longer, hotter summer in 1967.
其中最著名的就是纽瓦克和底特律的骚乱。这些可不像我们在英国经历的骚乱那样。这些骚乱中，有数十人、甚至上百人被枪杀。成千上万的人被枪杀。数千人受伤，伴随着打砸抢烧。有些城市 literalmente（字面意义上地）燃烧了好几天。如果你去谷歌搜索它们并查看图片或观看影像资料，就会发现那是宛如末日一般的景象：燃烧的街道，头戴防毒面具、手持步枪的国民警卫队员站在那里。
Most famously the riots in Newark and Detroit. And these are not like, you know, when we have riots in Britain. These are riots in which dozens of people, scores of people are being shot dead. Thousands of people are being shot dead. Thousands of people are injured, looting, burning. Some cities are literally burning for days. And if you Google them and look at the images or look at the footage, these are apocalyptic scenes of kind of burning streets, national guardsmen standing there with rifles with them gas masks on.
你知道，这看起来就像世界末日降临一般。有一张著名的照片，拍的是LBJ坐直升机飞越骚乱现场上空。那场景看起来就像越南战场。是的，完全如此。人们有一种感觉，低烈度的内战已经在美国内城区的核心地带爆发了。当然，当时人们使用的就是这种夸张的修辞。因此，这引发了针对政府的强烈反弹。
You know, it looks like something from the sort of the end of the world. It's in the famous photo of LBJ in a helicopter going over a riot scene. And it looks like Vietnam. Yeah, exactly. There's a sense that a sort of low level civil war has exploded in the heart of America's inner cities. Certainly that's the inflated rhetoric that people use at the time. So that provokes a backlash against the administration.
人们开始觉得：“天哪，我们厌倦了这些宏大的社会计划，我们厌倦了被强行‘改造’。受够了所有关于贫困的空谈。实际上，我们希望政府把这一切都解决掉，把重点放在打击犯罪上。”因此在1966年的中期选举中，共和党人取得了非常好的成绩。正是在这次中期选举中，罗纳德·里根凭借严厉打击骚乱、整顿社会无序状态的法律与秩序纲领，当选为加利福尼亚州州长。因此，里根在60年代末突然成为了一个炙手可热的名字。但更宏大的议题是越南。在这一点上，约翰逊继承了肯尼迪的承诺，随后又对其进行了大幅深化。那么，这就像民权运动那样是他真心信仰的，还是他只是因为
There's a sense that people think, gosh, we're sick of these big social programs, we're sick of being improved. Enough of all this talk about poverty. Actually, we want the government to sort all this out, focus on crime. So in the 1966 midterm elections, the Republicans had done really well. These are the midterm elections in which Ronald Reagan becomes governor of California on a law and order clamped down on the unrest, clamped down on the disorder ticket. So Reagan is suddenly a name to conjure with in the late sixties. But the even bigger issue is Vietnam. So here, Johnson had inherited this commitment from Kennedy and then had massively deepened it. So is it like the civil rights movement that he believes in it or is he just doing it because
觉得“既然骑上了虎难不成还能半路掉头”？不，我认为他是真的坚信这一点。事实上，历史学家之间存在着一场巨大的史学争论，我们现在由于时间关系无法深入探讨：即约翰逊本人是否应该为卷入这场战争承担责任，或者实际上他本不必这么做，却因为想要证明自己、因为他真心相信冷战那一套而选择这么做，等等。
he feels, well, you can't turn around at all, tanker? No, I think he does believe in it. And indeed there's a great historiographical debate between historians, which we can't really get into now because we don't have time, about whether Johnson is personally to blame for getting into the war, whether actually he didn't need to do it and he chose to do it because he wants to prove himself, because he genuinely believes in it, because he believes in the Cold War, all of this kind of stuff.
我的意思是，这场战争是否本可避免是另一个时段的话题了。但我们可以说的是，到了1965年，他认为自己已经从国会获得了空白支票。他把海军陆战队员送上了岘港（Da Nang）岸边，这是美军地面部队首次投入越南战场。从那一刻起，在接下来的三年里，他和他的指挥官们不断宣称：“隧道尽头有曙光。”我们将很快消灭南越的叛乱，并击败北越的共产主义者。再加把劲。完全没错。但那束曙光从未出现。于是日复一日，他们不断向那里倾泻更多的
I mean, whether or not they could have been averted is a subject for another time. But what we can say is that by 1965, he thinks he's got a blank check from Congress. He's sent the Marines ashore at Da Nang, which is the first commitment of kind of ground troops in Vietnam. From that point onwards, for the next three years, he and his commanders are constantly saying, there's light at the end of the tunnel. We will soon see off the insurgency in South Vietnam and we'll defeat the communists in North Vietnam. One last push. Exactly. But that light never comes. And so month after month, they're pouring in more
军队。因此，到1968年初，有超过五十万美军驻扎在南越，这是一个极其庞大的数字。现在，其中大约有两万名美国人已经阵亡。并且大多数死亡病例都发生在相当近的时期。事实上，在1968年还将有1.7万人丧生。当然，这还不包括所有那些身受重伤、患上严重创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）以及遭遇各种惨剧的人。而且征兵制当时已经引入了吗？是的。征兵制已经出台了。
and more troops. So by the beginning of 1968, there are more than half a million American troops in South Vietnam, an extraordinarily high number. Now of those, about 20,000 Americans have been killed by this point. And the most of the deaths have come quite recently. And indeed in 1968, another 17,000 will be killed. And of course, this doesn't count all those who have been badly injured, who've got massive PTSD, all of these kinds of things. And has the draft been introduced by this point? Yes. So the draft has been introduced.
所以这是导致……是的。实质上的强制兵役在年轻人中，尤其是大学校园里，引发了巨大的不满情绪。不过你确实有机会伴随着门乐队的音乐在田野里冲锋陷阵。所以至少还有这个。如果你喜欢那种调调的话。我觉得你只需要在脑海里想象一下那个背景音乐就行了，汤姆。
So that's an additional cause of... Yeah. Effective conscription causing great unhappiness among younger people and especially on college campuses. Although you do get to rush through fields to the soundtrack of The Doors. So there is that. Yeah. If you enjoy that kind of thing. I think you just have to imagine the soundtrack though, Tom.
我想现场并不会为你播放背景音乐。哦，好吧。所以问题在于，为什么约翰逊不直接撤军？实际情况是，到了1967年底，他和他的助手们已经陷入了一种“地堡心态”。他们厌倦了被批评。因此，政府内部持不同政见的人害怕大声疾呼。而且约翰逊是一个非常、非常骄傲且敏感的人。因此，他最亲密的助手之一乔治·里迪（George Reedy）曾这样评价约翰逊：
I don't think the soundtrack is laid on for you. Oh, okay. So the question is why doesn't Johnson just withdraw? And actually what's happened is that by the end of 1967, he and his aides have developed a kind of bit of a bunker mentality. They're sick of being criticized. So people who dissent within the administration are frightened of speaking up. And Johnson is a very, very proud and prickly man. So one of his closest aides, George Reedy, said of Johnson,
他一生中从未学会承认错误。而这种品质——对于一个私下里的人来说可能仅仅显得有趣或令人恼火（当然我们俩都不是那样的人，汤姆）——在约翰逊身上却演变成了一场宇宙级的悲剧。约翰逊坚信自己的声望——他做出了介入越南的决定，并相信他的声望甚至字面意义上的男子气概——都与之紧密相连。因为有一个非常著名的事件：当他被记者盘问“为什么你们在越南？为什么美国不撤军？”时，据说他解开了
he had never in his entire life learned to confess error. And this quality, merely amusing or exasperating in a private person, obviously neither of us are like that, Tom, resulted in the case of Johnson in cosmic tragedy. Johnson believes his prestige, he's made this decision to get involved in Vietnam and he believes his prestige indeed, I mean literally his manhood, are bound up with it because there's a very famous incident when he's being interrogated by reporters, why are you in Vietnam? Why does America not get out? And he is supposed to have unzipped
裤子拉链，把自己的身体暴露出来并说：“这就是原因。”这是真的吗？我的意思是，这听起来太像苏维埃托尼乌斯笔下的故事了。这是一个你一听就会怀疑并非属实的故事。这个故事是由他的联合国大使亚瑟·戈德堡（Arthur Goldberg）讲出来的。我是说，难道是他编造的吗？问题在于，关于LBJ的故事实在是太多了。为什么偏偏这个……但试想一下特朗普。想象一下特朗普在举行记者招待会时做出这种举动。我的意思是……是的，但这不是在直播……我是说，这又不是上了电视什么的。是的，但你这是在对记者做。但约翰逊确实干过这种事。他确实经常向人们暴露自己的身体。难以置信。而且他觉得这没什么不对的。所以无论如何，
his trousers, exposed himself and said, this is why. Is that true? I mean, that sounds very seetoneous. It's the kind of story that you suspect is not true. So it's told by his ambassador to the UN, a guy called Arthur Goldberg. I mean, did he make it up? The trouble is there are so many such stories about OBJ. Why would this one... But imagine Trump. Imagine Trump is holding a press conference and he does that. I mean... Yeah, but this isn't live on... I mean, it's not like it's on TV or something. Yeah, but you're doing it to journalists. But Johnson did do this. He did expose himself a lot to people. Unbelievable. And he thought there was nothing wrong with it. So anyway,
他们一直在把更多部队填进这个绞肉机里。汤姆，你刚才问到了征兵制。反战运动实际上从1965年就已经开始壮大了。我可以说，它最初源于一些规模很小的和平主义团体，尤其是——你听了可能会高兴——宗教团体、基督教团体、贵格会等等。所以起初是贵格会。但随后它不断壮大，显然征兵制度的存在，在战争持续期间总共征召了大约两百万人前往越南服役。总的来说，按常理讲，你越富有、受教育程度越高，逃避兵役的机会就越大。
they have been feeding more troops into this meat grinder. And you asked about the draft, Tom. The anti-war movement has been growing really since 1965. It began, I would say, originally with very small kind of pacifist groups, and particularly, you'll be pleased to hear, with religious groups, Christian groups, Quakers and so on. So it's the Quakers. But then it grew and grew, and obviously the existence of the draft, the draft conscripts in total about two million people over the lifetime of the war to serve in Vietnam. Now, basically, as a rule, the richer and better educated you are, the more chance you have of escaping.
你的脚后跟可以长骨刺。唐纳德·特朗普就没有去越南。比尔·克林顿在90年代也陷入了关于他涉嫌逃避兵役的巨大争议中。如果你是一个贫穷的学生，或者干脆不是学生，又或者如果你是个黑人，你上前线的几率就要高得多。因此，尽管大学生有更大的机会不去前线，他们依然对征兵制度的存在感到震惊。所以在1967年，你看到了大学校园里爆发的大规模抗议，其中最著名的抗议莫过于1967年向五角大楼进军，华盛顿特区聚集了超过十万人。
You get a spur in your foot. Donald Trump did not go to Vietnam. Bill Clinton got in terrible controversy about in the 1990s about what, how he had supposedly dodged the draft. If you're a poor student or indeed not a student student or if you are black, you've got a much higher chance of going. So even though students have a better chance of not going, they are horrified by the existence of the draft. So by 1967, you have huge protests on college campuses, most famous protest of all, the march on the Pentagon in 1967, more than a hundred thousand people
他们非常著名地试图对五角大楼进行“驱魔”，然后试图让它“悬浮”起来。太嬉皮士了。所以这些就是嬉皮士。汤姆，听到他们最终没能成功让五角大楼悬浮起来，你一定会大失所望的。嗯，真遗憾。是的。那么，大多数普通美国人是怎么想的？我猜你接下来要说这个。但这确实是事实。我的意思是，我接下来要说的话完全符合事实。这正是Pike's Ambroke（注：此处为幽默俚语/口误，指正中肯綮）。
in Washington DC. And they very famously try to exorcise the Pentagon and then to levitate it. So groovy. So these are the yippies. It will come as a great disappointment to you, Tom, to hear that they did not succeed in levitating it. Well, that's the man. Yes. So most ordinary Americans, what do they think? I know what you're going to say here. But it's true. I mean, what I'm going to say is just factually correct. This is Peek's Ambroke.
我的意思是，实际上，汤姆，别忘了，我当年在历史学术生涯刚起步时，可是为我的博士学位研究过这个的。所以正是这段经历塑造了我的世界观。我懂。这就是为什么它如此引人入胜。现实情况是，大多数普通美国人基本上都支持这场战争，并且一直支持战争。其实他们比讨厌战争更讨厌的一件事是——嬉皮士。是嬉皮士。
I mean, the thing is actually, Tom, don't forget, I did this for my PhD at the beginning of my historical career. So it's actually doing this that formed my worldview. Yeah, I know. This is, this is why it's so fascinating. The reality is that most ordinary Americans pretty much supported the war, always supported the war. The one thing they hated more than the war actually was hippies. Was hippies.
完全正确。他们讨厌的是反战运动。而且其中很大一部分人始终认为，我们其实应该把这场战争打得更狠一点。如有必要，我们应该打进北越。我们应该派军队进入北越，一路打到河内，以那种方式赢得战争。但我认为可以公平地说，公众普遍存在一种疲劳感。即使你支持这场战争，到了1968年你也已经对它厌烦透顶了。而且有一种明确的感觉：进步派的大都市舆论，尤其是受过大学教育的年轻人，在68年初已经彻底倒戈反对约翰逊了。因此在这一整年里，
Correct. It was the anti-war movement. And there's a large proportion of them always that thought we should actually fight the war harder. We should go into North Vietnam if necessary. We should send troops into North Vietnam, fight our way to Hanoi and win the war that way. But I think it is fair to say there is a general sense of weariness among the public at large. Even if you support the war, you're sick of it by 1968. And there's a definite sense that progressive metropolitan opinion, and especially the college educated young, have turned against Johnson by the beginning of 68. So all through
确切地说，在我们即将制作的整个系列节目中，我想你必须始终想象这样一幅画面：大学校园正处于叛乱之中。在纽约的哥伦比亚大学、在加州的伯克利，聚集了大量留着长发、高喊口号、挥舞标语牌、与当局对抗的人群，应有尽有。因为事实确实如此。还有那句口号：“喂，喂，LBJ，你今天害死了多少个孩子？”那是著名的口号，对吧？完全正确。那我能问一下吗，LBJ是一个坚定的进步派。我的意思是，他推出了所有这些非常具有进步色彩的自由派立法。他大概会觉得这些嬉皮士和进步派应该站在他这一边。
this year, and indeed all through this series that we're going to be doing, I think you have to imagine at the whole time, the campuses are in revolt. That at Columbia, in New York, and Berkeley, and California, there are massive crowds of people with huge hair, shouting and waving placards and fighting the authorities and all of it. Because there are. And there's the, hey, hey, LBJ, how many kids did you kill today? That's the famous slogan, isn't it? Exactly. And can I just ask, so LBJ is a massive progressive. I mean, he's introduced all this very progressive liberal legislation. And presumably he thinks that these kind of hippies and progressives should be on his
我的意思是，他们不买账，他会感到难过吗？他当然难过了。他感受到了巨大的背叛感。他确实如此。如果你不理解约翰逊觉得自己受到了多少围攻、背叛、背后捅刀子之类的感受，你就无法理解他的行事方式，因为他觉得这些人本该是……
side. I mean, does he feel upset that they're not? Of course he does. He feels a massive sense of betrayal. He does. You don't understand how Johnson behaves if you don't get how much he feels embattled, betrayed, stabbed in the back, all of these kinds of things, because he thinks these people should be...
他的人。他的人，而且他们应该心怀感激。我的意思是，他会在白宫里说：“这些孩子，这些势利眼的孩子，他们应该为我为他们所做的一切对心怀感激。”所以他把这解读为对方是精英阶层。绝对是的。我的意思是，这就是进步派精英阶层。毫无疑问。
His people. His people and they should be grateful. I mean, he will say in the White House, these kids, these snobbish kids, they should be grateful to me for all I've done for them. So he interprets it as they are the elite. Definitely. I mean, this is the progressive elites. Definitely.
他的人民。他的人民，他们应该心存感激。我的意思是，他会在白宫里说，这些孩子，这些高傲自大的孩子，他们应该为我为他们所做的一切对我感恩戴德。所以他把这理解为他们就是精英。绝对的。我的意思是，这就是进步派精英。绝对的。
Who don't understand. I mean, of course, Nixon thinks this even more strongly in their following administration, and we will get on to Nixon towards the end of this series. So Johnson is sitting there in the White House. It's a bit of a bunker mentality, terrible news from the cities, terrible news from Vietnam. His popularity is in free fall. It's kind of falling all the time. Wherever he goes by the end of 1967, there are massive protests. He cannot visit a college campus without there being a huge crowd of people who will chant at him exactly what you said. Hey, hey, LBJ, how many kids did you kill today? They really are saying that all the time.
谁不理解。我的意思是，当然，尼克松在他们接下来的政府中对此有更强烈的看法，我们会在本系列快结束时谈到尼克松。所以约翰逊正坐在白宫里。这有点像掩体心态，来自各大城市的糟糕消息，来自越南的糟糕消息。他的声望正在自由落体。它一直在某种程度上下降。到 1967 年底，无论他走到哪里，都有大规模的抗议活动。他不可能访问大学校园，而没有一大群人向他大喊你刚才说的话。嘿，嘿，LBJ，你今天杀了多少孩子？他们真的无时无刻不在这么说。
That's- Oh, they totally are. Yeah. Right. Shouting murderer, shouting Seekhile, all of this. Putting flowers in rifle butts. They are doing. They did that at the march of the Pentagon. So that's where the famous photos come from. That there are soldiers drawn up the march of the Pentagon. So that's where the famous photos come from. That there are soldiers drawn up in front of the Pentagon to defend it from the people who want to levitate it.
那是——哦，他们完全是。是的。对。大喊杀人犯，大喊齐奎尔，诸如此类。把花插在步枪枪管里。他们在做。他们在向五角大楼行军时做到了。所以这就是著名照片的来源。五角大楼前集结了士兵来保卫它，抵御那些想要将它悬浮起来的人。
And you know, these kind of well-meaning students are sort of giving them flowers and stuff. This is very, very late sixties. I mean, my heart doesn't bleed for Johnson particularly because I don't think he's a terribly attractive character, but there is no doubt that he feels a crushing sense of political pressure. He says to people, he feels like he's living in a continuous nightmare. I feel like a hitchhiker on a Texas highway in the middle of a hailstorm. I can't run, I can't hide, I can't make it go away. He can't sleep. He's got these huge mood swings. He's very depressed. At the end of 1967, one of his critics in the Democratic Party, a guy called George McGovern, came to dinner at the White House to one of the White House kind of banquets.
你知道，这些好意的学生在给他们送花之类的东西。这是非常非常六十年代末的事情。我的心没有为约翰逊特别流血，因为我不认为他是一个非常迷人的性格，但毫无疑问，他感到了巨大的政治压力的压迫感。他对人们说，他觉得自己生活在一个持续的噩梦中。我觉得自己就像德克萨斯州高速公路上的一个搭车客，正处于冰雹风暴的中心。我不能跑，我不能藏，我无法让它消失。他睡不着。他的情绪波动很大。他非常沮丧。1967年底，民主党内的一位批评家，一个名叫乔治·麦戈文的家伙，来到白宫吃晚宴，参加白宫的一种宴会。
And he was shocked by Johnson at this. And this is somebody who doesn't agree with him. He said, he seems a tortured and confused man, literally tortured by the mess he's gotten into in Vietnam. He is restless, almost like a caged animal. And what is also on Johnson's mind, I think, at the beginning of 68 is he's not a wellman. Johnson had been a massive drinker and a massive smoker. And in 1955, when he was 46 years old, he had had a heart attack and he is terrified
他对约翰逊的这种表现感到震惊。这是一个不同意他观点的人。他说，他似乎是一个饱受折磨和困惑的人，字面意思上饱受他在越南陷入的混乱局面的折磨。他坐立不安，就像一只被关在笼子里的动物。我认为，在 68 年初，约翰逊脑子里想的还有一件事，那就是他的身体不太好。约翰逊曾经是个极度酗酒和吸烟的人。1955年，当他46岁的时候，他心脏病发作了，他吓坏了。
he's going to have another heart attack or stroke. He always said that he used to look at the picture of Woodrow Wilson in the red room, Wilson who had had a stroke at the end of the first world war and been incapacitated for his kind of last period in the White House. And Johnson says, I worry that that will be me, that I under all this pressure, I'm going to have a heart attack and that will be the end of me. Dominic, would it thrill you if I read a line from this book I've read? I would, do you know what?
他将再次心脏病发作或中风。他总是说，他过去常常看着红室里伍德罗·威尔逊的照片，威尔逊在第一次世界大战结束时中风，并在他在白宫的最后一段时间里丧失了工作能力。约翰逊说，我担心那会是我，在所有这些压力下，我会心脏病发作，那将是我的终点。多米尼克，如果我朗读我读过的这本书里的一行，你会感到兴奋吗？我会的，你知道吗？
I can't think of anything at this point that I would enjoy more. I genuinely would love it. Throughout his presidency, he was in almost daily pain from angina and popped nitroglycerin tablets like jelly beans. Oh, well, there you go. I'm just adding a bit of extra texture. That's lovely texture. I think everybody enjoyed that. I know you'd be thrilled by that. So he has been for months saying to his wife, Lady Bird, oh, I think I might throw in the towel. But Johnson always
此时此刻我想不出有什么比这更让我享受的了。我真的会很喜欢。在整个总统任期内，他几乎每天都饱受心绞痛的折磨，像吃果冻豆一样吞服硝酸甘油片。哦，好吧，那就这样吧。我只是增加一点额外的质感。那是极好的质感。我想每个人都很喜欢。我知道你会为此感到兴奋的。所以他几个月来一直对他的妻子伯德夫人说，哦，我想我可能会认输。但约翰逊总是
says things like that because of his self-pitying kind of affection craving personality. He's always sort of threatening to leave in order to make people say, no, no, no, please don't. Please stay. Yeah. So no one takes it seriously. Meanwhile, from the end of the summer of 1967, some student activists and liberal activists who are almost sort of professional do-gooders, I guess, they're the kind of link people between
说这样的话，因为他那种自我怜悯、渴望关爱的性格。他总是以威胁要离开的方式，让人说，不，不，不，请不要。请留下。是的。所以没有人把它当回事。与此同时，从 1967 年夏天结束开始，一些学生活动家和自由派活动家，他们几乎可以说是职业做好事的人，我想，他们是……之间的某种纽带人物。
student groups and anti-war groups and all of this kind of thing. In the Democratic Party, they have been saying we should put up a candidate against Johnson in the Democratic primaries, a dump Johnson candidate. Now this has only really happened once before in 1952 that somebody has challenged the sitting president. So this was when a guy called Estes Kefauver, who you may remember from our JFK series, beating JFK to the vice presidential nomination in 1956, Estes Kefauver had beaten Truman. That wasn't a massive story. I mean, it was a bit of a story, but it's not a massive story.
学生团体和反战团体以及所有这类事情。在民主党内，他们一直说我们应该在民主党初选中推举一个反对约翰逊的候选人，一个抛弃约翰逊的候选人。现在这实际上只发生过一次，在 1952 年，有人挑战在任总统。所以当时一个叫埃斯特斯·凯福费尔的家伙，你可能从我们的肯尼迪系列中还记得他，在 1956 年击败肯尼迪获得副总统提名，埃斯特斯·凯福费尔击败了杜鲁门。那不是什么惊天大新闻。我的意思是，这有点像个故事，但这不是什么惊天大新闻。
So people don't really think about that as a precedent, but they are thinking we can fly the flag, we can fly the peace flag against Johnson, the democratic primaries humiliate him and maybe he will change course. Someone needs to stand up and say something. So the aim isn't actually to defeat him, just to make a statement. I'm not convinced that they think Johnson can be beaten. I think they've regarded as important to make a moral stand. The one person, of course, who could beat him, who at least has the national celebrity to beat him, is Robert F. Kennedy. And these activists go to Kennedy in Washington and they say, would you consider
所以人们并不真的把这当作先例，但他们在想我们可以升起这面旗帜，我们可以升起反抗约翰逊的和平之旗，在民主党初选中羞辱他，也许他会改变路线。总得有人站出来说点什么。所以我们的目标实际上不是击败他，只是为了表明态度。我不确信他们认为约翰逊会被击败。我认为他们认为进行道德立场的表态很重要。当然，唯一能击败他、至少拥有击败他的全国知名度的人是罗伯特·F·肯尼迪。这些活动家来到华盛顿找肯尼迪，他们说，你会考虑吗？
doing it? Kennedy, as we will discuss when we come to his episode, he doesn't really want to do it because he thinks it's very risky. You know, divide the party. Plus, Johnson will only do one more term and then it's my go in 1972. So he says, you know, guys, I'd like to, I completely support your cause, but I don't want to do it. So now they're looking for a stalking horse, you know, not a big name. And Dominic, do they find one? And if so, who is it? Well, they go around the halls of Congress. They ask a series of people who they know are against the war.
这样做？正如我们稍后在他的那一集里讨论的那样，肯尼迪其实并不想这么做，因为他认为这风险太大了。你知道，分裂党派。另外，约翰逊只会再干一个任期，然后轮到我在 1972 年上台。所以他说，伙计们，我很乐意，我完全支持你们的事业，但我不想这么做。所以现在他们在寻找一个诱饵马，你知道，不是什么大人物。多米尼克，他们找到了吗？如果是的话，是谁？好吧，他们走遍了国会大厅。他们询问了一系列他们知道反对战争的人。
So George McGovern, Frank Church, all these kinds of senators. And they're basically all these people say no. And then eventually they go all the way down the list and they find this kind of name towards the end of the list. This guy from Minnesota called Eugene McCarthy, they go in to see him and he listens to them and then he says, okay, I'll do it. And he, Tom, is going to change the course of American history. Brilliant. Okay, well, let's take a break there. And when we come back, we will hear
比如乔治·麦戈文、弗兰克·丘奇，所有这些参议员。基本上所有这些人说不。然后最终他们顺着名单往下找，在名单快结束的时候找到了这个名字。明尼苏达州的这个家伙叫尤金·麦卡锡，他们进去见他，他听了他们的话，然后说，好吧，我干。他，汤姆，将改变美国历史的进程。太棒了。好吧，那我们在那里休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将听到
about Eugene McCarthy from Dominic, the man who more than anyone else in the world is qualified to tell us all about him. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're looking at the fall of LBJ and Dominic, a stalking horse has been found in the form of Eugene McCarthy. Who is Eugene McCarthy and has an eminent presenter on this show perhaps done a doctorate on him? So yeah, Tom, I don't know how to say this to the listeners other than to say I did do my PhD on him.
关于尤金·麦卡锡，多米尼克将为我们讲述，他是世界上最有资格向我们介绍他的一切的人。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦点缀的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。你好，欢迎回到《历史就是一切》。我们正在关注 LBJ 的倒台，多米尼克，以尤金·麦卡锡的形式找到了一匹诱饵马。尤金·麦卡锡是谁，这个节目的杰出主持人是否曾对他做过博士学位？所以，汤姆，我不知道该怎么对听众说，除了说我确实做过关于他的博士学位。
I am literally the expert. That's the one thing I can claim to be an expert on. I think as I've said to you, Tom, nobody in the history of the human race will ever know more about Eugene McCarthy than I did at least. I've probably forgotten a lot. And Eugene McCarthy himself is dead. So he's not a rival to you. No.
我简直就是专家。这是我唯一敢自称是专家的事情。我想正如我对你所说的那样，汤姆，人类历史上的任何人，至少在当时，都不会比我更了解尤金·麦卡锡。我可能已经忘了很多。而且尤金·麦卡锡本人已经去世了。所以他不是你的对手。不。
And in fact, he and I have unfortunately had a difference of opinion about him. So what did he say? Well I interviewed him for my, he was very generous. He was very hospitable. I mean, we went for lunch. We had very nice time. Met him in Washington and in Minnesota. That was all lovely. But then after my PhD was published, became a book and was published, he said, he told the press that I was, and I quote, I'm apologies to our listeners, he said I was a shit and that my PhD was so bad, it was almost libelous. Right.
事实上，他和我在他身上不幸有不同的看法。那么他说了什么呢？我为我的项目采访了他，他非常慷慨。他非常热情好客。我的意思是，我们去吃了午饭。我们度过了非常美好的时光。在华盛顿和明尼苏达见过他。这一切都很可爱。但后来我的博士学位发表后，成了一本书并出版了，他说，他告诉媒体我是，我引用一下，我向听众道歉，他说我是个混蛋，我的博士学位太糟糕了，简直就像是诽谤。对吧。
Well, that's a commendation. All I can say is, you know, I'm obviously party pre, so people should make up their own minds after listening to the podcast and perhaps even if they can get down to the charity shop buying a copy of the book. Well, so what did he say about him? I mean, tell us about him. So he was born in 1916 in a place called Watkins, Minnesota, which I've been to, which is, I don't really recommend as a holiday destination. It's a sort of small Plains town, German Catholics largely who lived there. He's of German Catholic descent himself, despite the, I mean, the Irish name obviously, but it's the German influence I think is more important on him.
好吧，这是一份赞扬。我只能说，你知道，我显然是有偏见的，所以大家在听完播客后应该自己做决定，甚至如果他们能去慈善商店买一本这本书的话。好吧，那他说了什么？我的意思是，给我们讲讲他吧。他于 1916 年出生在一个叫沃特金斯的明尼苏达小镇，我去过那里，我真的不推荐把它作为度假胜地。这是一个平原上的小镇，居住的大多是德国天主教徒。他本人也有德国天主教血统，尽管，我的意思是，这个名字显然是爱尔兰名字，但我认为德国的影响对他更重要。
So he's out there in the middle of nowhere in Minnesota, no offence to people from Minnesota. He was educated by Benedictine monks. And then he actually became a Benedictine novice himself. I mean, very unusual. He's like Tony Abbott, the former Prime Minister of Australia. Yeah. So a very unusual sort of upbringing, I would say, for an American politician, a frontline American politician in the 1960s.
所以他远在明尼苏达的荒郊野岭，无意冒犯明尼苏达人。他接受的是本笃会修士的教育。然后他自己实际上成了一个本笃会修士初学修士。我的意思是，非常不寻常。他就像托尼·阿博特，澳大利亚前总理。是的。所以，对于一个美国政治家，一个 20 世纪 60 年代的美国一线政治家来说，这是一种非常不寻常的成长背景。
He was kicked out of the monastery basically after having a personality clash with the novice master. Because Eugene McCarthy was a very clever boy and was basically always showing off and laughing at everybody and saying he was much cleverer than they were. Sounds charming. And the novice master said this was very un-Christian behaviour. The sin of pride.
他被赶出了修道院，基本上是因为与初学修士导师发生了性格冲突。因为尤金·麦卡锡是个非常聪明的男孩，基本上总是爱炫耀，嘲笑所有人，并说他比他们聪明得多。听起来很有魅力。初学修士导师说这是非常不基督教的行为。骄傲之罪。
The sin of pride. So then he got married and he and his wife tried to set up a kind of Catholic rural commune. This is in the Great Depression. He's really into all this kind of sort of guild business and distributive justice and all these Catholic ideas. And that didn't really work out. He then went to St. Paul, the state capital of Minnesota and he became a sociology lecturer. And he got into politics. He was elected by the Democratic Farmer Labor Party, which is the name of the Democratic Party in Minnesota for St. Paul, sent to Congress. And then he worked his way up. He was very
骄傲之罪。于是他结婚了，他和他的妻子试图建立一种天主教的乡村公社。这是在大萧条时期。他真的对所有这类行会生意、分配正义以及所有这些天主教思想很感兴趣。但这并没有真正成功。然后他去了明尼苏达州的首府圣保罗，成了一名社会学讲师。他涉足政治。他被民主党农民劳工党选举为圣保罗代表，该党是明尼苏达州民主党的分支，并被派往国会。然后他一步步晋升。他非常
good at politics. He was very bright. He's kind of handsome. He's articulate. He's a rising star. He's liberal, but he's not kind of too liberal. So he kind of gets on with the big party fix. People like LBJ, the party barons, and he is elected to the Senate from Minnesota in 1958. So he's on the liberal wing of the party, but he's still quite unusual because he's kind of, it's like a European Christian Democrats or something, but a very pious one. He's massively into Thomas Aquinas and Thomas Moore. He's quoting them in his speeches all the time.
擅长政治。他非常聪明。他长得挺帅。他口齿伶俐。他是一颗冉冉升起的新星。他是自由派，但又不是那种过于自由派。所以他和党内大佬们相处得很好，像 LBJ 这样的大佬，他于 1958 年从明尼苏达州当选为参议员。所以他属于党内的自由派，但他仍然很不寻常，因为他有点像欧洲基督教民主党人什么的，但却是一个非常虔诚的人。他非常痴迷于托马斯·阿奎那和托马斯·莫尔。他在演讲中一直在引用他们。
People would go to his office in the Senate and they would say, everybody else has like the congressional record, books about American politics. He has very ostentatiously, they would say. He has all these books about sort of medieval theology and stuff. And people would always say about him, you know, he wears his learning and his cleverness extremely heavily. I remember this story, it's somewhat of the oral history interviews at the Kennedy Library, I think it's Ted Kennedy or somebody like that tells the story. They said they once got a plane with him to some speaking function in the middle of nowhere. And they all
人们去他在参议院的办公室，他们会说，其他每个人都有国会议事录、关于美国政治的书籍。他们会说，他非常显眼地拥有所有这些关于中世纪神学之类的书。人们总是这样评价他，你知道，他毫不掩饰自己的学识和聪明才智。我记得这个故事，这是肯尼迪图书馆口述历史采访中的一部分，我想是肯尼迪或类似的人讲述了这个故事。他们说他们曾和他一起坐飞机去某个荒郊野岭的演讲活动。他们都
got on the plane and they're reading like, yeah, the other senators are reading Ian Fleming, or they're reading the newspaper, or they're doing a bit of work and he kind of reaches into his bag and he took out this enormous Catholic missile and just sort of reading it in front of everybody in a very, very ostentatious way. So that's basically how he carries on. But he likes poetry as well, doesn't he? He also writes poetry. So he's really into his poetry and he's influenced by people like Yates and kind of modernist poets and he writes his own poetry. Again, Tom, I think I'm probably the only person would ever have on the podcast who's read every single one of Eugene McCarthy's poems. Are they good or derivative? I think you can be both good and derivative.
上了飞机，他们在看，是的，其他参议员在看伊恩·弗莱明，或者他们在看报纸，或者他们在做点工作，而他把手伸进包里，拿出了这个巨大的天主教祈祷书，就在所有人面前以一种非常非常显眼的方式读了起来。所以他基本上就是这样行事的。但他也很喜欢诗歌，不是吗？他也写诗。所以他真的很喜欢诗歌，并且深受叶芝等现代主义诗人的影响，他自己也写诗。同样，汤姆，我想我可能是这个播客中唯一一个读过尤金·麦卡锡每一首诗的人。它们是好还是衍生出来的？我想你可以既好又衍生。
Like Oasis. Yes, like Oasis. He's the oasis. He's the Noel and Liam Gallagher of 1960s American politicians. Yeah, he has a very dry kind of style. I think they are very derivative, but I don't think, he's not talentless. Right, I mean, he's still, yeah, they're better poems than I could write. Let's put it that way. So he's a poetry writing Aquinas fan.
像绿洲乐队。是的，就像绿洲乐队。他是绿洲乐队。他是 20 世纪 60 年代美国政客中的诺尔和利亚姆·加拉格尔。是的，他有一种非常冷嘲热讽的风格。我认为它们非常衍生，但我不认为，他并非没有才华。好吧，我的意思是，他仍然，是的，它们比我能写的诗要好。这么说吧。所以他是一个写诗的阿奎那粉丝。
Yeah. He sounds very like he's going to do well in the 60s. The other thing that he has, now this is, I think, what he objected to in my description of his career. He has what I think we could safely describe as a very distinctive personality. And Tom, it worries me that you will find this disturbingly familiar, because when I
是的。他听起来很像会在 60 年代做得很好的人。另一件事是，现在这就是我认为他反对我对他的职业生涯的描述的地方。他拥有我们可以安全地描述为非常独特的个性。汤姆，我担心你会觉得这令人不安地熟悉，因为当我
did all these interviews and I went and did, went through the archives, the same comments kept coming up again and again. So right from when he was at school, his English teacher said, and I quote, he enjoyed it when someone made a fool of himself in class. One of the monks at the monastery, he had little regard for people not as talented or as sophisticated. So what was it drew you to write about Senator, you don't want to know? Yeah, it was the commonality of temperament. So in that book you quoted an American melodrama. There's a wonderful description by these British reporters.
做了所有这些采访，并查阅了档案时，同样的评论一次又一次地出现。所以从他在学校的时候起，他的英语老师就说，我引用一下，当有人在课堂上出丑时，他会很高兴。修道院里的一个僧侣说，他不太尊重那些不如他有才华或不如他世故的人。那么是什么吸引你写关于参议员的文章，你不想知道？是的，那是性格的共鸣。所以在书中你引用了《美国情节剧》。这些英国记者有一段精彩的描述。
His fellow politicians regarded him as aloof, indolent, arrogant and annoying. They didn't like the way he spent so much of his time telling wicked little stories about his colleagues to reporters. And the fact that the stories were always pointed enough to draw blood made it all the worse. They thought him quote, a truly deeply cynical man, a scoffer, as one puts it. Now it's important to say Tom, that we don't approve of such behaviour at all. And we would, the thought of us, for example, telling wicked stories about our podcasting colleagues is unthinkable. So it's no wonder that you wrote this book in a tone of deep moral disapproval. No, I didn't disapprove. You see, this is the thing. I put all this in the book and
他的同行政治家认为他冷漠、懒散、傲慢且令人讨厌。他们不喜欢他花那么多时间向记者讲他同事们的恶毒小故事。而这些故事总是足够尖锐，见血封喉，这让情况变得更糟。他们认为他，引用一下，是一个极其深刻的冷嘲热讽的人，一个嘲弄者，正如某人所说的那样。现在必须指出，汤姆，我们一点也不赞成这种行为。而且我们会，比如我们想象自己向播客同事讲述恶毒的故事，那是不可想象的。所以你带着深深的道德谴责的语气写这本书也就不足为奇了。不，我没有谴责。你看，这就是问题所在。我把所有这些都写进书里，并且
I thought this was brilliant. You thought you're paying him a compliment. I thought I was. Yeah. I think this is maybe the difference in the British and American sensibility that I actually genuinely thought this is absolutely brilliant behavior. This is exactly how I behave. But he and some of the American reviewers said, oh, this is very harsh. This is very unfair. Of course he wasn't like this at all. Well anyway, now he in the 1960s has already flirted with presidential politics. In 1960, he had basically he'd backed his Minnesota stablemate, a guy called Hubert Humphrey for the presidency, rather than Jack Kennedy. So Hubert Humphrey will be a big player in the story as well.
我以为这太棒了。你以为你是在恭维他。我以为我是。是的。我想这也许就是英国和美国审美的区别，我真的真诚地认为这绝对是绝佳的行为。这正是我自己的行为方式。但她和一些美国评论员说，哦，这太严厉了。这太不公平了。他当然不是这样的人。无论如何，现在他在 20 世纪 60 年代已经涉足了总统政治。1960 年，他基本上支持了他在明尼苏达州的同僚，一个名叫休伯特·汉弗莱的家伙竞选总统，而不是杰克·肯尼迪。所以休伯特·汉弗莱也将是这个故事中的一个重要角色。
Very big player. Yeah. Can I a kind of... Can I just say I'll be honest, I would never have heard of either of them if I hadn't heard them through you. Yeah. And the fact they're called Eugene and Hubert, I imagined them both as kind of slightly geeky, bowties, round glasses, kind of weedy. No. But no, I mean, they're massive great lads, aren't they? Yeah, I would say they're great lads. If you like talking about Thomas Aquinas or being kind, which are their respective traits, then I guess, yeah, you'd get on well with them. They'd be good on the podcast. I mean, Hubert Humphrey is a great talker. So he'd, yeah, you'd get on well with him.
非常重要的角色。是的。我能，一种……我能说句实话吗，如果不是通过你听到他们的话，我永远不会听说过他们中的任何一个。是的。而且他们叫尤金和休伯特的事实，我把他们想象成那种有点书呆子气、戴着领结、圆眼镜、有点孱弱的人。不。但不是，我的意思是，他们是很棒的小伙子，不是吗？是的，我会说他们是很棒的小伙子。如果你喜欢谈论托马斯·阿奎那或者保持善良，这是他们各自的特点，那么我想，是的，你会和他们相处得很好。他们在播客里会表现得很出色。我的意思是，休伯特·汉弗莱是个出色的谈话者。所以他，是的，你会和他相处得很好。
Well, it just goes to, you shouldn't judge on a name, you know, leap to leap your expectations from names. So anyway, Eugene is backing his Minnesota friend, Hubert Humphrey. The person he despises is Kennedy. He goes around saying to everybody that the Kennedys are total lightweights and playboys, and he's very, very offended that they're Catholics. He says they're terrible Catholics and I'm a brilliant Catholic. He actually said famously to a guy called Tip O'Neill, he said, I'm the
这说明，你不该单凭名字去判断一个人，你知道的，不要对名字抱有不切实际的期望。不管怎样，尤金在支持他来自明尼苏达州的朋友，休伯特·汉弗莱。他鄙视的人是肯尼迪。他到处对人说肯尼迪家族全都是无名小卒和花花公子，而且他对他们是天主教徒感到非常非常愤怒。他说他们是糟糕的天主教徒，而我才是一个杰出的天主教徒。他甚至对一个叫蒂普·奥尼尔的人说过一句名言，他说，我是
one who should be nominated. Any way you measure it, I'm a better man than John Kennedy. I'm smarter. I'm a better speaker. And if they're looking for a Catholic, I'm a better Catholic. Of course, I don't have a rich father. Dominic, do you know what that reminds me of? And this will mean nothing to you, but it may mean something to quite a lot of our listeners.
那个应该被提名的人。无论你从哪个角度衡量，我都比约翰·肯尼迪更优秀。我更聪明。我是个更好的演讲者。如果他们想找个天主教徒，我就是一个更好的天主教徒。当然，我没有一个有钱的父亲。多米ニック，你知道这让我想起了什么吗？这对你来说可能没什么意义，但对我们的许多听众来说可能意味深长。
It's Gretchen in Mean Girls when she's having her rant about Regina George, who's the queen bee in the film. And she compares herself to Brutus and says that Brutus is just as good as Caesar in very similar terms. So I wonder if Tina Fey was informed by that. I don't know. It seems implausible. Well, you never know. You do never know. So Kennedy is then shot, of course. McCarthy thinks, well, brilliant, I could be Lyndon Johnson's vice president. He needs somebody to balance the ticket. And everybody knows he's going to choose one of these two guys from Minnesota, Eugene McCarthy or Hubert Humphrey. And Johnson keeps saying to McCarthy, it's going to be you, it's going to be you,
这就好比《贱女孩》里的格雷琴，她在痛骂片中的女王蜂雷吉纳·乔治。她把自己比作布鲁图斯，并用非常相似的措辞说布鲁图斯和凯撒一样优秀。所以我在想蒂娜·菲是不是受到了这个启发。我不知道。这似乎不太可能。好吧，你永远说不准。你确实永远说不准。当然，肯尼迪随后遇刺身亡。麦卡锡心想，太棒了，我可以成为林登·约翰逊的副总统。他需要一个人来平衡竞选名单。而且人人都知道他将从明尼苏达州的这两个家伙中选择一个，尤金·麦卡锡或休伯特·汉弗莱。约翰逊一直对麦卡锡说，会是你，会是你，
bring your family to Atlantic city, to the convention, all of this kind of thing. And then right at the end, he chooses Huber Humphrey. And McCarthy is absolutely gutted. He is so gutted in fact, that after this, he basically goes into this massive strop. Yeah, a bit of a, I was going to say sulk. He basically just hangs around in the Senate for years. He's bored, He's incredibly bitter. He's contemptuous about all the other senators who he says are thick and not
把你的家人带到大西洋城的代表大会上来，诸如此类。然后就在最后关头，他选择了休伯特·汉弗莱。麦卡锡彻底崩溃了。事实上他如此沮丧，以至于在那之后，他基本上陷入了一场巨大的脾气暴躁中。是的，有点像——我本想说生闷气。他基本上就在参议院里混了好几年。他觉得无聊，无比痛苦。他轻视所有其他参议员，说他们愚蠢且不如
as good as him and so he makes himself quite a sort of unpopular figure, but he also turns against the administration over the Vietnam war. So he's genuinely horrified as some senators are by the bombing. His kids are against the war and they influence him. By about 1966 or so, 1967, he and about a dozen other Democrats have turned against the war and they say, look, we should do a couple of things. Number one, and these things will come up again and again in this series. Number one, stop the bombing of North Vietnam. We are dropping so much ordinance on them. It is brutal. It's killing thousands of civilians.
他优秀，因此他成了一个相当不受欢迎的人物。但同时，他也因为越南战争而开始反对政府。所以他和其他一些参议员一样，对轰炸感到真正的惊恐。他的孩子们反战，并影响了他。大约到1966年或1967年左右，他和大约十来个民主党人已经转向反战，他们说，听着，我们应该做几件事。第一，这些事情在本系列中会反复出现。第一，停止轰炸北越。我们投在他们身上的弹药太多了。这太残忍了。这正在杀死数千名平民。
It is indefensible. And number two, we should have a negotiated settlement. And that means basically everyone gets around the table and this may mean a coalition government in South Vietnam that includes the Viet Cong. Now Johnson and the White House say, this is bonkers, the Viet Cong. You can and the White House say this is bonkers, the Viet Cong, you can't have them in a coalition government, they would kill everybody and seize power. But the doves say no, no, no, this is the only solution. So there's this sort of ideological breach. But when these guys come to find their stalking horse candidates,
这简直不可理喻。第二，我们应该进行通过谈判解决。这意味着基本上每个人都坐到谈判桌前，这可能意味着在南越建立一个包括越共在内的联合政府。现在，约翰逊和白宫说，这太疯狂了，越共，你们怎么能让他们进入联合政府，他们会杀光所有人并夺取政权。但主和派说不，不，不，这是唯一的解决办法。所以这就产生了某种意识形态的分裂。但是当这些人寻找他们的敲门砖候选人时，
McCarthy, it seems in a way unlikely that McCarthy will actually do anything about it because he's made it very clear to a lot of his intimates, and this is something that I kind of found out a lot about when I was doing my PhD, that he wants to lead politics. He actually wants to be like the head of a university or something, a kind of college president. But then these guys come to see him, these activists, and he's sitting there in late 1967 and he thinks, well, why not? Why not have a presidential campaign? It wouldn't be the worst thing in the world, right?
麦卡锡，在某种程度上看来，麦卡锡不太可能会对此采取任何行动，因为他已经向他许多亲信明确表示过——这也是我在攻读博士学位时了解到的很多情况——他其实并不想领导政治。他实际上想成为一所大学的负责人什么的，比如某种大学校长。但随后这些人来找他，这些活动人士，他在1967年底坐在那里心想，好吧，为什么不呢？为什么不进行一次总统竞选呢？这也不会是世界上最糟糕的事情吧？
First of all, my kids would like it, campaigning against the war. And I genuinely, he genuinely is opposed to the bombing of North Vietnam and the waging of the war. And he genuinely wants it to end. It's not like I'm underplaying that side of him. And I think that's very important. But also I think he thinks it'd be a laugh, you know, it'd be a lark. He says to people, he says to the guy who becomes his campaign manager who told me this story, he said McCarthy said, it'll just be you and me touring these
首先，我的孩子们会喜欢它，进行反战竞选。而且我是真心——他是真心反对轰炸北越和进行这场战争。他是真心希望战争结束。我并不是在轻描淡写他这方面的一面。我认为这非常重要。但我也认为他觉得这会很有趣，你知道的，这会是一场闹剧。他对人们说，他对那个成为他竞选经理、向我讲述这个故事的人说，麦卡锡说，到时候就只有你和我去这些
campuses. Everybody will love us. We'll just be able to sit up at night with the students drinking whiskey and talking about poetry and it'll be great fun and he also thinks it'll make his name. He be able to charge more for i mean genuinely somebody said he told them it will increase my speaker fees. And he's been told there are a load of kind of progressive financiers and things in new york city have promised that they will be loads of money, that they will fund it properly. You know, he'll be traveling business class flights, nice rooms in hotels, you know, it'll all be properly organized. And there's another dimension.
校园巡回演讲。每个人都会爱死我们的。我们只需要在夜里和学生们坐在一起喝威士忌，谈论诗歌，那会非常有趣，而且他认为这也会让他名声大噪。他以后能收更高的出场费——我是说真的，有人说他告诉过他们，这会增加我的演讲出场费。而且有人告诉他，纽约市有一大批进步派金融家之类的人承诺会提供大量资金，他们会妥善资助。你知道的，他将坐商务舱航班旅行，住在漂亮的酒店房间里，你知道的，这一切都会被妥善组织好。还有一个维度。
He said to a liberal activist in Massachusetts, I've seen the interview, he said, I had every right to think that Johnson would pick me as his vice president. I invited my family to come down from Minnesota to Atlantic city. But then of course he didn't pick him. So McCarthy said, I vowed I would get that son of a bitch and I did. So this is what happens. He enters the race on the 30th of November and it's a very, very sort of funereal scene almost. He announces he's opposing Johnson. He says it's all going to be a referendum on Vietnam. The press are
他对马萨诸塞州的一个自由派活动人士说——我看过那个采访——他说，我有充分的理由认为约翰逊会选我做他的副总统。我邀请我的家人从明尼苏达州下来到大西洋城。但后来他当然没有选他。所以麦卡锡说，我发誓我要拿下那个王八蛋，而我确实做到了。所以事情就是这样。他在11月30日宣布参选，那几乎是一个非常非常凄凉的场面。他宣布反对约翰逊。他说这一切都将是对越南政策的全民公投。媒体都
astounded. They don't really take it seriously. There's a sort of one of them, Newsweek, he was all grey like a kind of essence, they said about McCarthy because he's got this sort of style which is very unflashy, very unexciting. He wants to talk about Catholic philosophy and poetry with you. And the Punic Wars, I gather. Yeah. So when he starts campaigning, right, this is the amazing thing. I love this stuff.
震惊了。他们并没有真正认真对待这件事。其中一家媒体《新闻周刊》说他灰头土脸的，就像某种精髓一样，他们这样评价麦卡锡，因为他的这种风格非常朴实无华，毫无激情。他想跟你谈谈天主教哲学和诗歌。还有布匿战争，我听说。是的。所以当他开始竞选时，这真是太神奇了。我太喜欢这段了。
When he starts campaigning, a couple of days after this announcement, he has this big address to a conference of concerned Democrats in Chicago. And they were absolutely pumped up. They're looking forward to this furious denunciation. USA! No, they're not shouting USA. They're shouting, hey, hey, hell be jade. Okay. Yes, of course.
当他开始竞选时，就在这个声明发布几天后，他在芝加哥对一个由关切的民主党人组成的会议发表了长篇大论。他们当时情绪高涨。他们期待着一场愤怒的谴责。美国！不，他们没有在喊美国。他们在喊，嘿，嘿，黑尔·贝杰。好的。是的，当然。
That's their thing. Yeah. But they're still whooping and chanting. Well, I think they're whooping. They're kind of earnest people, Tom. Okay. They are. They're very...
那是他们的口号。是的。但他们仍然在欢呼和高喊。好吧，我想他们在欢呼。他们是那种很认真的人，汤姆。好吧。他们确实是。他们非常……
Oh, well, if they're earnest, then they'll love what he serves up. Well, they're high minded and they want to hear a blistering denunciation of the war. McCarthy gets up and he goes up to the thing and he's basically says, I thought I'd give you a bit of a lecture about the lessons of the Punic war. I mean, he's my man. I'm all over it. And they are, they can't believe it. I mean, they're going mad. They hit the activists are so gutted that he's behaving like this. They would say to him like, we've organized a visit for at a factory gate. You're going to go and shake all these hands. And he literally said, quote, I'm not really a morning person.
哦，好吧，如果他们很认真，那他们会喜欢他端出来的东西。好吧，他们思想高尚，他们想听到对战争的猛烈抨击。麦卡锡走上台去，走到那个东西前，基本上说，我想给你们做个关于布匿战争教训的演讲。我的天，他真是我的菜。我完全被他折服了。他们简直不敢相信。我是说，他们快疯了。活动人士们感到极其沮丧，因为他竟然表现成这样。他们会跟他说，比如，我们已经组织了一次去工厂大门口的访问。你要去和所有人握手。而他居然说，原话是，“我其实不是个早起的人。”
Right. It's like me organizing trips to Chatham high street or on ferries. And you say, no, I'm not going to. He will have a text. He will be given a text of like a denunciation of the war and he'll go up and he'll still read a bit of it and then he'll get bored and he'll say, I'm going to read you some of my poems actually. And it is as though he is, and this is exactly what I think he's doing by the way, I think
对吧。这就像我组织去查塔姆商业街或乘渡轮旅行一样。而你说，不，我不去。他会有一份稿子，会给他一份诸如谴责战争的稿子，他走上去，还是会读一读其中的一部分，然后他就觉得无聊了，然后他会说，其实我要给你们读几首我的诗。这就好像他在——而这正是我认为他当时在做的事情，我认为
he's mocking the conventions of presidential politics because basically he thinks he's too good for it. So LBJ must hate that. Yeah. Well, I think LBJ just thinks it's comical. He doesn't take it seriously at all, because within weeks, McCarthy's poll rating tanks. So by the end of January 1968, he's behind LBJ by 71 to 18%. And one of the previously vaguely supportive columnists, so in the sort of village voice,
他在嘲笑总统政治的常规，因为基本上他觉得自己比这高贵得多。所以林登·约翰逊一定恨死这个了。是的。嗯，我想林登·约翰逊只觉得这很滑稽。他一点也不把这当回事，因为在几周内，麦卡锡的民调支持率就暴跌了。所以在1968年1月底，他以71%对18%落后于林登·约翰逊。其中一个以前稍微有点支持倾向的专栏作家，在类似《乡村之声》这样的报纸上——
kind of began as a kind of alternative newspaper in New York, Jack Newfield, and he wrote at the time, McCarthy's campaign is a disaster. It's so inept that it seems that only a paranoid view of his intentions can explain its failure. Oh, yeah. It's a parody. It's a parody. Or indeed that he's been put up to this by Johnson. Right. Yeah.
它最初是纽约的一份另类报纸，杰克·纽菲尔德，他在当时写道，麦卡锡的竞选是一场灾难。它是如此无能，以至于只有用对他意图的偏执看法才能解释它的失败。哦，是的。这是一场闹剧。这是一场闹剧。或者确实他是被约翰逊推出来干这个的。对吧。是的。
Like one of those people that runs against Vladimir Putin. Yeah. You know, he's an approved person to siphon off discontent and to be useless so Johnson can cruise to victory. And then there is a stunning twist. We do like a kind of bombshell on the rest is history. And this is a real bombshell. Clouds of war are gathering, right? So it's the afternoon of the 30th of January and Johnson's in the White House when his national security advisor, Walt Whitman Rostow comes in and says to him, we've had reports from Saigon, there is gunfire near the presidential palace
就像那些与弗拉基米尔·普京竞选的人一样。是的。你知道的，他是一个被批准的人选，用来分流不满情绪，并且毫无用处，这样约翰逊就可以轻而易举地走向胜利。然后出现了一个惊人的转折。我们“历史的其余部分”播客确实喜欢这种重磅炸弹。这真的是一颗重磅炸弹。战争的阴云正在聚集，对吧？所以那是1月30日的下午，约翰逊正在白宫，他的国家安全顾问沃尔特·惠特曼·罗斯托走进来对他说，我们收到了来自西贡的报告，总统府附近发生了枪击事件，
and there is gunfire in the grounds of the U S embassy. That's not good. And LBJ says, oh, this sounds very bad. And he is right. Cause this is the beginning of the Tet Offensive, which is the beginning. It's the new year in Vietnam. It is a sort of stunning surprise attack timed for the holiday by the Viet Cong and North Vietnamese soldiers in a hundred different towns and cities across South
美国大使馆的场地上也发生了枪击事件。这可不妙。林登·约翰逊说，哦，这听起来很不妙。他是对的。因为这是新春攻势的开始，也就是序幕。这是越南的新年。这是越共挑选在节日期间、在南越
Vietnam. It's the biggest military operation of the war so far. It completely takes the Americans by surprise. The most famous images of it, so there's one moment, which is the Viet Cong fight their way into the compound of the US embassy. I mean, that is a stunning symbolic blow to American pride. But it is only symbolic, isn't it? Because the Tet Offensive actually gets defeated.
一百多个城镇同时发动的令人震惊的突然袭击。这是战争中迄今为止最大规模的军事行动。它完全打了美国人一个措手不及。其中最著名的画面是，有一个时刻，越共打入了美国大使馆的大院。我的天，这对美国人的自尊心是一个沉重的象征性打击。但这只是象征性的，不是吗？因为新春攻势实际上被击退了。
Yeah, and they lose tens of thousands of men, the Viet Cong. However, it's the fact that the US didn't see it coming. It's the fact that the fighting has taken place in the citadels of South Vietnamese and American military power in the capital city is just staggering to American audiences at home. There is a sense that middle America realizes for the first time the generals have been lying to us. There is no light at the end of the tunnel. Yeah, the US embassy is not safe. There's a very famous photo which lots of people will have seen,
是的，越共损失了成千上万的人。然而，事实是美国人没有预料到这一点。事实是，战斗竟然发生在南越和美国军事力量在首都的堡垒中，这让国内的美国观众感到震惊。人们有一种感觉，美国中部的人们第一次意识到将军们一直在对我们撒谎。隧道尽头没有光亮。是的，美国大使馆并不安全。有一张非常著名的照片，很多人都见过，
which becomes the emblematic picture. It's on the 1st of February, so a couple of days later, and it's by a guy called Eddie Adams, and it shows the Saigon chief of police just almost casually shooting this bloke in the head in the middle of the street, a captured Viet Cong prisoner. And as LBJ's aide said at the time, the photo was in every newspaper and it seemed to capture this sense that America had blundered into a horrendous conflict. I quote, we were sunk in a war between alien peoples with whom we shared few human values. Of course, that's very loaded comment.
它成了标志性的图片。那是2月1日，也就是几天后，由一个叫埃迪·亚当斯的人拍摄的，照片显示西贡警察局长在街头中央，几乎是若无其事地朝一个被俘的越共囚犯的头部开枪。正如约翰逊的助手当时所说，这张照片登上了每一份报纸，似乎捕捉到了美国陷入了一场可怕冲突的那种感觉。我引用一下：“我们深陷于一场与异族人民之间的战争，我们与他们几乎没有共同的人类价值观。”当然，这是一个带有强烈主观色彩的评论。
That's from LBJ's aide Harry McPherson. But that I think expresses how a lot of Americans felt. Their troop losses mount in the following weeks. They're using more men proportionately than the South Vietnamese Army. Even LBJ's own advisors are beginning to crack at this point. So the Secretary of Defense, Robert McNamara, who had been Kennedy's Secretary of Defense before, he had been seen as the sort of the absolute early sixties, mad men style, master of the universe, number cruncher. He'd been a car company executive. He never showed a
这是约翰逊的助手哈里·麦克弗森说的。但我认为这表达了许多美国人的感受。在接下来的几周里，他们的部队伤亡人数不断上升。按比例计算，他们动用的人数甚至超过了南越军队。甚至连约翰逊自己的顾问此时也开始崩溃了。因此，国防部长罗伯特·麦克纳马拉——他以前曾是肯尼迪的国防部长，他一直被视为那种绝对的六十年代初期“广告狂人”风格的、精通数字的宇宙主宰。他曾是一家汽车公司的执行官。他从未流露出
flicker of emotion. He's kind of Dr. Strange Love isn't he? Yeah well he's the master of all the figures and the stats and he's the ultimate kind of corporation man I guess, McNamara. And at one of these meetings at the end of February he literally breaks down in tears. The other LBJ aides are so embarrassed. He says to them between kind of sobs, our goddamn air force is dropping more on North Vietnam than we dropped on Germany in World War II and it is not doing anything. Then he turns to a guy sitting along the table from him called Clark Clifford who's going to succeed him as Secretary of Defense. McNamara says to Clifford, we just have to end this thing.
一丝情感。他有点像奇爱博士，不是吗？是的，他是所有数字和统计数据的掌门人，我想麦克纳马拉是终极的体制内大人物。在2月底的一次会议上，他真的崩溃得哭了。约翰逊的其他助手感到非常尴尬。他在啜泣声中对他们说，我们该死的空军在北越投下的炸弹比我们在二战中对德国投下的还要多，而这根本不管用。然后他转向坐在他桌子对面、即将接替他担任国防部长的克拉克·克利福德。麦克纳马拉对克利福德说，我们必须结束这一切。
I just hope you can get hold of it because it has got completely out of control. And everybody is kind of, oh my God, the generals are asking for more troops. Our guys in Washington are just crying and they've, they've lost control of it. And he'll go on to make a film, won't he? Famous film. Fog of War. Fog of War. Yeah.
我只希望你能控制住局面，因为它已经完全失控了。每个人都感到，天哪，将军们在要求更多的军队。我们在华盛顿的人都在哭泣，而且他们已经、他们已经失去了对局面的控制。他后来去拍了一部电影，对吧？著名的电影。《战争迷雾》。《战争迷雾》。是的。
I've, I've met Robert McNamara. I've interviewed him. He cried in front of me. Did he? But I mean, that was his party piece. It's like the French Revolution. He cried in front of me. Did he? But I mean, that was his party piece. It's like the French Revolution. He cried in front of everybody.
我、我见过罗伯特·麦克纳马拉。我采访过他。他在我面前哭了。真的吗？但我的意思是，那是他的拿手好戏。这就像法国大革命一样。他在我面前哭了。真的吗？但我的意思是，那是他的拿手好戏。这就像法国大革命。他在所有人面前哭泣。
Everyone crying. Yeah. He came to Cambridge when we were doing our PhDs. Everybody who was doing sort of work on this period had to present their work to him. And that was a weird thing, right? He's sitting there kind of at the end of this room and you had to say, well, I think you thought this and, and he was actually charming. I remember him coming for lunch, sitting there in his anorak, eating these terrible sandwiches provided by university
每个人都在哭。是的。当我们在攻读博士学位时，他来到了剑桥。每一个做这时期研究的人都必须向他展示他们的研究成果。那是一件很奇怪的事情，对吧？他坐在房间的尽头，你不得不说，嗯，我想你是这么想的，而且他其实很迷人。我记得他来吃午饭，穿着冲锋衣坐在那里，吃着大学餐饮部提供的糟糕的三明治，
catering, a bit of a come down, I have to say. And talking to him about the war and he just, and somebody had said to us before, and he'll almost certainly start crying. That's what he always does. And he did. And, you know, it was kind of the, well, everyone wants to see anyway. So there's been, I think a definite shift against the war at this point. It's symbolized by the most famous newscaster of the day, Walter Cronkite. He goes to Vietnam, he comes back and he says on television, it's clear to me now we've totally lost control of this thing. He says, I think we're not going to win.
不得不说，这有点大跌眼镜。和他谈论战争时，他只是——有人之前对我们说，他几乎肯定会开始哭泣。他总是这样。他确实哭了。而且，你知道的，这有点像，反正每个人都想看。所以此时对战争的态度绝对发生了一个明确的转变。这以当时最著名的电视新闻主播沃尔特·克朗凯特为象征。他去了越南，回来后在电视上说，现在我很清楚，我们已经完全失去了对局面的控制。他说，我认为我们不会赢了。
We should negotiate not as victors, but as honorable people who lived up to their pledge to defend democracy and did the best they could. And that night LBJ says to his aides, well, if I've lost Walter Cronkite, I've lost the country. So this is the context in which people are going to go to the polls in the first primary contest. So McCarthy and Johnson. Was that any influence on the timing of the offensive?
我们应该以荣誉之人的身份去谈判，而不是以胜利者的姿态，我们要兑现保卫民主的承诺，尽力做到最好。那天晚上，林登·约翰逊对助手说，好吧，如果我失去了沃尔特·克朗凯特，我就失去了整个国家。这就是人们即将在第一场初选投票中面临的背景。所以麦卡锡和约翰逊。这对比利时攻势的时机有影响吗？
No. The Viet Cong kind of thinking about this. They're not interested in that. There's no doubt that Hanoi, the North Vietnamese, do follow American politics. They're very conscious of it. And we'll come to this when we come to Nixon and Nixon's election. But at this point, the whole McCarthy thing is such a sideshow. I mean, most people just think it's absolutely going to go nowhere at all.
没有。越共考虑这件事的时候，根本不关心这个。毫无疑问，河内，也就是北越，确实在关注美国的政治。他们对此非常清楚。等我们讲到尼克松以及尼克松的竞选时，还会谈到这一点。但此时，整个麦卡锡事件只是个微不足道的插曲。我的意思是，大多数人只是觉得它绝对不会有什么结果。
The first primary is going to be in New Hampshire on the 12th of March. And in the grand scheme of things, it doesn't really matter. Have you ever been to New Hampshire, Tom? No. It's kind of New England, but it's quite gritty New England. So a lot of industrial towns, Irish and French Canadian Catholic voters. There are some college towns, but by and large it's more hawkish than a lot of the New England states. So I think generally the sense was they probably will, LBJ will be fine here. This isn't really massively, you know, it's not as studenty as some places.
第一场初选将于3月12日在新罕布什尔州举行。从宏观大局来看，这其实并不重要。汤姆，你去过新罕布什尔州吗？没有。那里的新英格兰风情有点粗犷。有很多工业城镇，还有爱尔兰裔和法裔加拿大籍天主教选民。有一些大学镇，但总体而言，它比许多新英格兰州更主张强硬。所以我认为大家的普遍感觉是，他们可能会支持，林登·约翰逊在这里应该没问题。这里其实并没有那么，你知道的，不像某些地方那样充满学生气。
But the thing is, because McCarthy is actually, his style is quite conservative, because he's talking about Hannibal and, you know, St. Augustine and stuff. He doesn't scare people. People think he's like a kind of sober, restrained university professor. Norman Mailer, who wrote loads about the 68 campaigns, wrote everything in McCarthy's manner. His quiet voice, his offhand delivery, his resolute refusal to etch his wit with any hint of emphasis gave a hint of his profound conservatism. And I think there's a lot of truth in that. And he's quite ambiguous. So he goes around
但问题是，因为麦卡锡实际上，他的风格相当保守，因为他谈论的是汉尼拔，你知道的，圣奥古斯丁之类的事。他并不吓人。人们觉得他就像那种头脑清醒、温和克制的大学教授。诺曼·梅勒写了大量关于68年竞选的文章，他完全用麦卡锡的风格进行了描述。他平静的声音、随意的语调、坚决不用任何语气词来突显其机智的风格，都隐约透露出他骨子里的深刻保守。我认为这其中有很多真实之处。而且他相当含糊。所以他到处
saying to everybody, God, the Tet Offensive, what a shambles that was. That shows we're doing really badly in the war, doesn't it? Will you lend me your vote? He doesn't really spell out in very clear terms, whether he's for the war or against the war. So a lot of people actually, I think, voted for him thinking he would prosecute the war more aggressively than Johnson. And is that a deliberate strategy or just that his pitch is muddled? I think there's a degree of deliberate strategy about it. Actually, I don't think it's completely cynical, but I do think there's a sense in which, and
对每个人说，天哪，春节攻势，那真是一团糟啊！这表明我们在战争中打得很糟，不是吗？你会把选票投给我吗？他并没有用非常明确的术语来阐明自己究竟是支持战争还是反对战争。所以我认为，实际上有很多人投票给他，以为他会比约翰逊更积极地推进战争。这是一种深思熟虑的战略，还是说他的立场本来就很混乱？我认为这其中带有一定程度的深思熟虑的战略。实际上，我不认为这完全是玩世不恭，但我确实认为，某种程度上，
a bit of studied ambiguity when you're running in a presidential campaign, as we will see with Nixon, is no bad thing. Um, what he's basically doing, I think, is he is saying, if you don't like LBJ for whatever reason, vote for me, what's the worst that could happen? And of course there are lots of people on different sides of the spectrum who don't like LBJ who think, why not a protest vote? It's a bit like voting for the Lib Dems in Britain. You know, it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter what they stand for.
在总统竞选中保持一点刻意的含糊其辞，正如我们随后将在尼克松身上看到的，并不是件坏事。嗯，他基本上在做的是，他在说，如果你因为什么原因不喜欢林登·约翰逊，那就投给我吧，最坏能有什么结果呢？当然，政治光谱不同阵营里有很多人都不喜欢林登·约翰逊，他们会想，为什么不投一张抗议票呢？这有点像在英国投票给自由民主党。你知道的，这无所谓。他们主张什么并不重要。
I just want to express my dissatisfaction. He's the underdog. It's a romantic little campaign. Yeah, I'll vote for him. But he also has a secret weapon that nobody has ever really thought to deploy in American politics before. Students. People up to this point had thought having lots of students was
我只是想表达我的不满。他是弱势候选人。这是一场浪漫的小型竞选。好吧，我会投给他。但他还有一个秘密武器，一个以前在美利坚政治中从没人想过要动用的秘密武器：学生。在此之前，人们一直认为拥有大量学生
probably a bit of a bad thing. So Robert Kennedy had sent a message to McCarthy and had said, tell McCarthy, he's going to get loads of student volunteers because they're all very excited about the war. Tell him to be careful. He'll have more than he knows what to do with. Let him look out for that. And this is quite wrong. He gets about 10,000 students, I think. Their numbers are always inflated. So most of the books you read, let's talk of this huge army, 50,000 people or more. I don't think it was ever that many, but they're all from these kind of prestigious Northeastern universities, New England universities, Yale, Boston University, Dartmouth, Harvard. The great thing that everybody who knows about this story knows is that they went so-called
可能是一件有点糟糕的事。罗伯特·肯尼迪曾给麦卡锡捎过口信，说：“告诉麦卡锡，他会得到大批学生志愿者，因为他们都对这场战争非常兴奋。告诉他要小心。他会有应接不暇的人手。让他提防这一点。”这完全是大错特错。我记得他大约得到了10,000名学生。他们的数字总是被夸大。所以你读的大多数书里，都会提到这支庞大的军队，5万甚至更多人。我认为从来没有那么多，但他们都来自这些负有盛名的东北部大学、新英格兰大学，比如耶鲁、波士顿大学、达特茅斯、哈佛。了解这个故事的人都知道，最棒的一点是他们进行了所谓的
clean for Jean. Meaning they turned up with massive beards and big hair because they're kind of hippie-ish students. And actually they're then shaved off their beards to go canvassing. They made the supreme sacrifice for their country and their cause of peace. Hairies and freaks, that was the sort of claim. Actually, I don't think his students were hairies and freaks. That was the sort of claim. Actually, I don't think his students were hairies and freaks. They were square, earnest. Well, Al Gore is one of them, right? Al Gore would be the epitome. There were people who were really into politics, who like would give up their time to go knocking
“干净纯洁行动”（Clean for Jean）。意思是他们本顶着大胡子、留着长发出现，因为他们有点像嬉皮士学生。实际上他们随后刮掉了胡子去挨家挨户拉票。为了国家和和平事业，他们作出了至高无上的牺牲。毛发凌乱的怪胎，这就是当时的某种说法。实际上，我认为他的学生并不是毛发凌乱的怪胎。这只是当时的某种说法。实际上，我认为他的学生并不是毛发凌乱的怪胎。他们古板而又认真。嗯，阿尔·戈尔就是其中之一，对吧？阿尔·戈尔就是其典型代表。这些人对政治非常热衷，愿意牺牲自己的时间去敲
on doors and handing out leaflets. Almost by definition, they're not people who are just smoking loads of dope and growing their beards. Anyway that's by the by. It's a very, very effective campaign because people in New Hampshire love the fact that all these kids are turning up. Sort of. It's like the Mormons, I guess. Yeah. Kind of crisp white shirts. May I have your vote, mom? All that. Yes. That's exactly what it is. Kind of pretty young women.
门、散发传单。几乎从定义上讲，他们绝不是那种只知道抽大量大麻、留着大胡子的人。不管怎样，那都是题外话。这是一场非常非常有效的竞选，因为新罕布什尔州的人们非常喜欢这些年轻人纷纷涌来的情景。有点像摩门教徒，我猜。是的。那种笔挺的白衬衫。妈妈，能把选票投给我吗？诸如此类。是的。完全就是这样。长相甜美的年轻女性。
Yeah. Their best jeans or... Princesse. Yeah. They're nice dresses. They're coming up knocking on your door. Can I give you a leaflet? A guy called McCarthy. Oh yeah, I'll consider it. He's also got some celebs.
是的。穿着他们最好的牛仔裤或……公主裙。是的。穿着漂亮的裙子。他们走上前来敲你的门。能给你一份传单吗？一个叫麦卡锡的人。哦，好吧，我会考虑的。他还拉拢了一些名人。
We love a celeb. He's got Robert Vaughan from The Man From Uncle. He's got Lauren Bacall and he's got Catwoman. Oh, brilliant. From Batman. From Batman. Oh, fantastic. And this was when Batman was good.
我们都爱名人。他有出演《来自叔叔的男人》的罗伯特·沃恩。他有劳伦·白考尔，还有猫女。哦，太棒了。来自《蝙蝠侠》。来自《蝙蝠侠》。哦，太绝了。而且这还是《蝙蝠侠》很好看的时候。
Exactly. No, it's the Adam West period. It's your favorite period of that one. Yeah. And is it true that people get him muddled with Senator Joe McCarthy, as in the McCarthy trials? Is that not true? I don't think it is true. Now, this is something obviously that I had to endure in my brief academic career. Because whenever I said I was doing my PhD on him, I had written my first book and then people said, what, Joe McCarthy? Red scares? Oh, brilliant. Love that. And I had to be like, no, it's the one that no one's ever heard of. But no, he told this story himself. He said he made a joke that people would vote for him because they thought he was Joe McCarthy. And since then it was always repeated. People
没错。不，那是亚当·韦斯特时期。那是你最喜欢的那个时期。是的。人们会把他和参议员约瑟夫·麦卡锡（也就是麦卡锡主义听证会里的那个）搞混，这是真的吗？难道这不是真的吗？我认为这不是真的。看，这显然是我在自己短暂的学术生涯中不得不忍受的事情。因为每当我告诉别人我的博士学位研究方向是他时，我都已经写了我的第一本书，然后人们就会说：“什么？约瑟夫·麦卡锡？红色恐慌？哦，太棒了。我喜欢这个。”然后我不得不说：“不，是那个从来没人听说过的人。”不过说真的，他自己也讲过这个故事。他说他曾开玩笑说，人们会投票给他，是因为他们以为他就是约瑟夫·麦卡锡。自那以后，这个说法就一直被反复提及。人们
said, oh, everybody voted for him because they think. But I don't think they did. I've been, not that they were that stupid. It's good to know he made a joke. Oh yeah, he did make some. Between all the stuff about the Punic Wars and the poetry. Oh, he did make jokes. He would make these very kind of elliptical... The snide. Yes, I would say snide because I don't want him to be haunting me from beyond the grave.
说：“哦，每个人投票给他都是因为他们以为……”但我认为他们没那么做。倒不是说他们真的那么蠢。很高兴知道他开过玩笑。哦，对，他确实开过一些玩笑。在那些关于布匿战争和诗歌的言论之间。哦，他确实会开玩笑。他会说那些非常隐晦的……尖酸刻薄的话。是的，我会说尖酸刻薄，因为我可不想让他从坟墓里跳出来纠缠我。
I've already done enough damage. But I would say he would make, I think he would make sardonic jokes, Tom. Yeah, of course. I think that's what he would do. Now, the one thing everyone gets wrong is everybody says, I've seen it in all the new books about 1968 that have come out in recent years, a shoestring campaign, an underdog effort. Absolutely not true. His campaign was one of the best finance campaigns to that point in American history because he had all this money from Wall Street. So he spent, I think in total, $11 million, the most expensive democratic primary
我已经惹够麻烦了。但我要说的是，他会开，我认为他会开一些辛辣的玩笑，汤姆。是的，当然。我想他就是那样的人。现在，每个人都弄错的一点是，大家都说——我在近年出版的所有关于1968年的新书中都看到过——这是一场资金拮据的竞选，是一次弱势群体的抗争。绝对不是真的。他的竞选是美国政治史上迄今为止资金最充足的竞选之一，因为他拥有来自华尔街的所有这些资金。所以他总共花费了，我想大约是1100万美元，这是民主党初选历史上
campaign that had ever been waged. He outspent Johnson in New Hampshire by three to one. So he's throwing a lot of money at it. There's a lot of leaflets, there's a lot of posters and well, I was about to say it works, but actually the one thing that everybody really gets wrong is he still loses. So it's always treated as a victory, right? So on the 12th of March, 1968, New Hampshire votes, LBJ with all the resources of the presidency, everyone expected him to win a massive landslide.
进行过最昂贵的竞选。他在新罕布什尔州的竞选资金开支是约翰逊的三倍。所以他在其中投入了巨额资金。有大量的传单、大量的海报，而且——我正要说这起作用了，但实际上，每个人都完全弄错的一点是，他最后还是输了。所以这总是被当作一场胜利来对待，对吧？因此，在1968年3月12日，新罕布什尔州进行投票，林登·约翰逊拥有总统职权的所有资源，所有人都预计他会取得压倒性的大胜。
Well, you know how McCarthy would frame it. What would he say? He would say that Johnson has won a victory, but it's a Pyrrhic victory. He absolutely would. Drawing on his knowledge of Roman history. Well, it's exactly what people say. So Johnson won 49% of the votes, McCarthy won 42% because of some obscure business about delegates that I've
嗯，你知道麦卡锡会如何定义它。他会说什么？他会说约翰逊赢得了一场胜利，但这是一场惨胜。他绝对会这么说。这取材于他对罗马历史的了解。嗯，这正是人们所说的。所以约翰逊赢得了49%的选票，麦卡锡赢得了42%，因为有一些关于代表的晦涩事务，我
actually never really been bothered to try and find out why. McCarthy wins more delegates, 20 out of 24 delegates from New Hampshire. He has this huge victory party at the Sheraton Hotel in Manchester, New Hampshire. I mean, Manchester, New Hampshire, I've been to Manchester, New Hampshire. I wouldn't massively recommend it as a destination. But anyway, there's loads of kids, you know, shouting victory and doing peace side stuff. I have to say they haven't actually won, but yeah, let them have their moment. In the next day's papers on TV, everybody says McCarthy has basically won.
其实从来没有真正费心去弄清楚原因。麦卡锡赢得了更多代表，新罕布什尔州24名代表中有20名支持他。他在新罕布什尔州曼彻斯特的喜来登酒店举行了盛大的庆祝派对。我是说，曼彻斯特，新罕布什尔州，我去过那里。我绝不会强烈推荐它作为一个旅游目的地。不过不管怎样，那里有成群的孩子，你知道的，高喊着胜利并摆出和平手势。我必须说他们其实并没有真正获胜，但好吧，让他们享受这一刻吧。在第二天报纸上和电视上，每个人都说麦卡锡基本上赢了。
I mean, I know technically Johnson has won, but it's a Pyrrhic victory. Isn't this wonderful? This is the most extraordinary moment in American political history. The monk, the poet, the guy nobody had ever heard of when they thought he was somebody else. He's kind of beaten Johnson, even though he hasn't. What an amazing thing. Hurrah, hurrah. And all this kind of thing. And McCarthy gets up there and he says, I think one of the most ironic things actually that anybody has ever said, if we come to Chicago with this strength, there will be no riots or demonstrations, but a great victory celebration. And we'll be doing an entire episode on how that didn't have to. Yeah, that didn't quite work out. So this is a shocking and seismic moment in American politics. LBJ is very badly wounded. Four days later, Robert Kennedy, who has said he will not run, steps out in the
我的意思是，我知道从技术上讲是约翰逊赢了，但这是一场惨胜。这难道不美妙吗？这是美国政治史上最不寻常的时刻。那个僧侣、那个诗人、那个在人们误以为他是别人的时候名不见经传的家伙。他竟然击败了约翰逊，尽管他实际上并没有击败。多么了不起的事情啊！万岁，万岁！诸如此类。然后麦卡锡站起来说，我认为这是任何人说过的话中最具讽刺意味的事情之一：如果我们带着这种实力来到芝加哥，将不会有任何骚乱或示威，而只有伟大的胜利庆典。我们将会制作一整集节目来讲述为什么事情并非如此。是的，那并没有完全按照计划进行。所以这是美国政治中一个令人震惊和震撼的时刻。林登·约翰逊遭受了重创。四天后，此前曾表示不会参选的罗伯特·肯尼迪，在参议院党团会议室露面了，就是他哥哥约翰当年宣布竞选总统时的同一间房间。这就是“水上王子”。他说：我参选了，我要与林登·约翰逊对决。对此我有着强烈的感受。现在对我来说很清楚了，我无法置身事外。所以这简直是刺向约翰逊心脏的一把匕首。而坐在白宫里的约翰逊震惊不已。
Senate caucus room, the same room in which his brother John had declared his candidacy for the presidency. This is the Prince over the water. And he says, I'm running, I'm running against LBJ. I have strong feelings about it. It's clear to me now that I can't stay out. So this is a dagger aimed at Johnson's heart. And Johnson sitting there in the White House is in shock.
他说
He says to an intern of his called Doris Kearns, who later wrote a book about this and became a very well-known biographer. He says, I felt that I'm being chased on all sides by a giant stampede coming at me from all directions, rioting blacks, demonstrating students, marching welfare mothers, squawking professors and hysterical reporters. And then the final straw, the thing I feared from the first day of my presidency was actually coming true. Robert Kennedy had openly announced his intention to reclaim the throne in the memory of his brother. And Johnson is a bully.
他对一个名叫多丽丝·卡恩斯的实习生说，她后来写了一本关于这件事的书，并成为了一位非常著名的传记作家。他说：“我感觉自己四面楚歌，正被一场从四面八方朝我涌来的巨大狂潮所追赶：暴动的黑人、示威的学生、游行的福利母亲、大喊大叫的教授和歇斯底里的记者。”然后是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，我从总统任期的第一天起就一直恐惧的事情终于成真了：罗伯特·肯尼迪公开宣布了他为了缅怀兄长而要收回王座的意图。而约翰逊是个霸凌者。
I mean, it's the sort of thing that primary school teachers always say about bullies. Oh bullies are cowards deep down. And in a way, I think there is a little bit that Johnson doesn't really fancy the fight. He gets news from Wisconsin, the next primary, his campaign manager goes out to Wisconsin, flies back to Washington and says, we're going to lose Wisconsin. I mean, this won't be a Pyrrhic victory. McCarthy is going to win two thirds of the vote. It's a big student state.
我的意思是，这就好比小学老师常对霸凌者说的那种话：哦，霸凌者内心深处其实都是懦夫。从某种意义上说，我认为约翰逊确实有点不想打这场仗。他收到了来自威斯康星州的消息，那是下一场初选，他的竞选经理前往威斯康星州视察，飞回华盛顿后说：“我们要输掉威斯康星州了。我的意思是，这可不是什么惨胜。麦卡锡将赢得三分之二的选票。这是一个学生众多的州。”
We are dead in Wisconsin. And then what? They look at the calendar, the next primaries, Oregon, California, New York. Is Johnson going to lose? Is he going to win any? Now he could still win the nomination. You don't need all the primaries, but he is looking at a really, really bruising spring. So he makes a decision. He's going to address the nation on the 31st of March to change the narrative. Sunday night, nine o'clock, live on TV. Nobody knows what's coming. So on that big day, Sunday the 31st, very early that morning at the White
“我们在威斯康星州彻底完蛋了。”那接下来呢？他们看了一下日历，接下来的初选是俄勒冈州、加利福尼亚州、纽约州。约翰逊会输吗？他能赢下任何一个州吗？现在他依然有可能赢得党内提名。你并不需要赢得所有的初选，但他即将面临一个非常非常令人心力交瘁的春天。于是他做出决定。他将于3月31日向全国发表讲话，以扭转叙事。周日晚上九点，电视直播。没人知道接下来会发生什么。所以在那个重要的日子——31日星期天，那天清早，在白宫，
House, Johnson's daughter, Linda flies in from California. She has left her husband, Chuck Robb, who is a Lieutenant in the Marines, who is about to be sent to Vietnam. Linda is heavily pregnant. She is in tears. She says to her father, why is my husband having to go to this country to fight, and I quote, for people who don't even want to be protected? And Johnson, I wanted to comfort her, but I could not.
约翰逊的女儿琳达从加利福尼亚乘飞机赶来。她离开了她的丈夫查克·罗布，后者是一名海军陆战队中尉，即将被派往越南。琳达怀有身孕。她泪流满面。她对父亲说：“为什么我的丈夫必须去这个国家打仗，引用原话，‘为那些甚至不愿意受到保护的人’而战？”而约翰逊说：“我想安慰她，但我做不到。”
He doesn't know what to say to her. So that morning, that afternoon, he's working on this speech that he's going to give. And that afternoon is done. He asks Vice President Humphrey to come in and he says, this is the speech. The speech will be a breakthrough. It will be an announcement that we're stopping the bombing of North Vietnam in an attempt to find peace. And Humphrey says to him, Humphrey is a very effusive guy. Humphrey says, Oh, Mr. President, that's a beautiful speech, just beautiful. I think it's the, it'll be the best speech you've ever made. And then LLBJ hands him a second piece of
他不知道该对她说什么。所以在那个早晨、那个下午，他一直在修改他准备发表的演讲稿。那个下午终于结束了。他请副总统汉弗莱进来，并说道：“这就是这篇演讲稿。这篇演讲稿将是一个突破。它将宣布我们停止对北越的轰炸，以此来寻求和平。”汉弗莱对他说——汉弗莱是一个非常热情洋溢的人——汉弗莱说：“哦，总统先生，这是一篇极好的演讲，简直太棒了。我认为这将是你发表过的最好的演讲。”然后林登·约翰逊递给他第二张
paper and he says, I've got an alternative ending here for the speech. I think you should read it. And Humphrey reads the speech, burst into tears. He's crying as well. He's crying as well. He's crying as well. So they're all at it. He says, Oh, Mr. President, you can't mean it. You can't mean it.
纸，并说道：“我这里为演讲准备了一个备选结局。我想你应该读一下。”汉弗莱读了这篇演讲，顿时泣不成声。他也哭了。他也哭了。他也哭了。所以他们全都在哭。他说：“哦，总统先生，你不是认真的吧？你不能这样。”
And Johnson says, I haven't made my mind up. If I'm going to use that ending, I will let you know that evening. The broadcast starts at nine o'clock and there's 85 million people watching. And Johnson is on screen and he looks haggard. He looks exhausted. It looks like he's aged a decade in months. And Humphrey still doesn't know which ending Johnson has chosen, which he's going to go with. And only after Johnson is speaking live, does Humphrey get a phone call. And it's a phone
约翰逊说：“我还没下定决心。如果我要使用这个结局，我会让你知道的。”那天晚上，广播于九点开始，有8500万观众在收看。约翰逊出现在屏幕上，他看起来面容憔悴。他看起来精疲力竭。他看起来像是在几个月里苍老了十年。而汉弗莱仍然不知道约翰逊选择了哪个结局，不知道他会采用哪一个。直到约翰逊正在进行现场演讲时，汉弗莱才接到一个电话。那是
call from one of Johnson's aides. The president says to tell you he has chosen the second ending. So Johnson is still talking. He says to people, I realize the desire for peace in Vietnam. I'm unilaterally suspending American bombing of the North and I'm inviting Hanoi for peace talks. And he goes on talking about what this settlement would look like. And then he looks at Lady Bird, his wife, who was just off camera, and he gives her a little signal with his hand. And that is a sign he is going with this second ending. And he says, look, I know America is very badly divided. And he quotes Abraham Lincoln, a house divided against itself cannot stand. And then he says, with American sons in the field far away,
约翰逊的一位助手打来的电话。总统说要告诉你，他选择了第二个结局。所以约翰逊仍在讲话。他对人们说：“我理解对越南和平的渴望。我单方面暂停美国对北方的轰炸，并邀请河内进行和平谈判。”他继续谈论这种和平协议将会是什么样子。然后他看着妻子伯德夫人，她就站在镜头外，他用手给妻子打了个微小的信号。那是他将采用这第二个结局的标志。他说：“听着，我知道美国严重分裂。”他还引用了亚伯拉罕·林肯的话：“自相纷争的家，站立不住。”接着他说，随着美国子弟兵远在异国他乡浴血奋战，
I don't think I should devote an hour or day of my time to any personal partisan causes or to any duties other than the awesome duties of this office, the presidency of your country, and then the line that sends shockwaves across the country. Accordingly, I shall not seek and I will not accept the nomination of my party for another term as your president. Unbelievable. The one man whose lust for power had driven him all his life has thrown in the towel. He's done.
我认为我不应该把哪怕一小时或一天的时间，花在任何个人党派事业上，或者除了履行这个办公室——你祖国的总统——那令人敬畏的职责之外的任何其他职责上。接着是那句在全国掀起轩然大波的话：“因此，我将不会寻求，也不会接受我的党派对另一个总统任期的提名。”难以置信。这个一生都被对权力的渴望驱使的人，竟然扔下了白毛巾。他完了。
He's gone. And so you spoke at the start of the episode about the parallels between 1968 and 2024. And this, I suppose, is the first glaring parallel. A sitting president who had been another Democrat president's vice president, who'd become president, achieved his great ambition standing down after one term. But the difference I think is that Biden stood down this year or withdrew from the race. Because he was forced to. After weeks of speculation, he had to be winkled out and it became unsustainable. With Johnson.
他退出了。所以在节目刚开始时，你谈到了1968年和2024年之间的相似之处。而这，我想，就是第一个显而易见的相似之处。一个在任总统，曾担任另一位民主党总统的副总统，后来成为总统，实现了自己的宏伟抱负，却在完成一个任期后宣布卸任。但不同之处在于，我认为拜登是在今年卸任或退出了竞选。因为他是被迫这么做的。在数周的猜测之后，他不得不被“挖”了出来，而这种局面已经变得不可持续。而对于约翰逊来说……
It's genuinely a bombshell. A massive, massive shock. People, you know, they knew it was going to be very tasty, the campaign for the Democratic nomination, but they never imagined that Johnson, of all people, a creature of politics who craves power so much, that he would just walk away. They can't believe it. Everybody is stunned. And for all of his rivals, so that's obviously McCarthy and Kennedy on the left, is Humphrey, his vice president. Then on the right, Richard Nixon, Ronald Reagan, Nelson Rockefeller, George Wallace down in Alabama. For all these people, this suddenly changes everything. Nobody knows now. The narrative that had seemed predetermined has
这绝对是一个重磅炸弹。一个极其巨大的震撼。人们，你知道的，他们知道民主党总统候选人的竞选将会非常激烈，但他们从没想过约翰逊——竟然是约翰逊，这个如此渴望权力、对政治乐此不疲的政客——会就此抽身离去。他们简直不敢相信。所有人都惊呆了。而对于他所有的竞争对手来说，也就是左翼的麦卡锡和肯尼迪，他的副总统汉弗莱，然后是右翼的理查德·尼克松、罗纳德·里根、纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，以及远在阿拉巴马州的乔治·华莱士。对所有人来说，这突然改变了一切原本看似命中注定的叙事，现在
now been thrown into total flux. Because when the mighty oak falls, other trees can sprout. Oh, great metaphorical stuff, Tom. But we talked about the beginning, about this parade, the succession of events. And just five days after this, an even more dramatic moment as the story of America in 1968 will take another and deadlier twist. So we will be back very soon with that episode in which we will be telling the story of the assassination of Martin Luther King. And if you want to hear that and the rest of the series,
彻底陷入了混乱。因为当伟大的橡树倒下时，其他的树木便能破土而出。哦，很棒的比喻，汤姆。但我们在开始时谈到了这场游行，一连串的事件。就在这之后的短短五天里，随着1968年美国故事迎来另一个更致命的转折，一个更加戏剧性的时刻即将上演。所以我们很快就会带着那一集节目回归，在节目中我们将讲述马丁·路德·金遇刺的故事。如果你想收听那一集以及本系列的其余内容，
right now, you don't have to wait. You can go to therestishistory.com and join the club. And you can, of course, also get tickets for our forthcoming tour of the United States. So Tom, I think there are still some seats in Philadelphia, in New York and in Los Angeles. So we hope to see you all there. See you then. Bye-bye.
现在你无需等待。你可以访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。当然，你也可以购买我们即将进行的美国巡演的门票。所以汤姆，我认为费城、纽约和洛杉矶仍然有一些座位。所以我们希望在那里见到大家。到时见。再见。
Bye-bye. in New York and in Los Angeles. So we hope to see you all there. See you then. Bye bye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。在纽约和洛杉矶。所以我们希望在那里见到大家。到时见。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。